if you like hunting and you like
capturing things and getting it and
having animal meet my brother cooks
raccoon for me when I visit him and God
I love him
then you got to check out the new hitter
hunting club collection now available at
theovanstore.com
we got hoodies and orange and maroon
camo hats traditional and orange
go over there and get that hitter and
more at theovanstore.com uh when I went
out some new tour dates we're adding
shows in Indianapolis
in Houston in uh Phoenix Arizona and in
New York City New York
um those are new additional added shows
they're available now you can go get
them as well we have shows in Louisville
Shreveport
uh Baton Rouge uh Corpus Christi on uh
and Austin Texas so you can go get a
hold of all those theovan.com
t-o-u-r you can get tickets get them
through there so you get fairly and
accurately priced tickets and not no
secondary tickets
thank you guys I look forward to seeing
you return to the rat tour
hey guys I want to thank you guys for
tuning in uh I also want to
just offer up the disclaimer that
today's episode
um contains material and stories and
discussions that
um can be pretty graphic uh they contain
violence
um they contain some gore
um they
they are real stories that uh this
police officer went through and so we
want to leave them in to honor
and get the experience of what their
life is like
um if you have
a problem
um hearing that sort of thing if if uh
graphic content
um
some of it can be sexual in nature some
of it
um is just contains some violence then
this may not be the episode for you I
just want to let you know that in
advance
uh thank you guys so much for the
support
today's guest is just a regular police
officer that's who he is
um and he also he made his way up to
detective at some point and he's not a
media figure
um he's not a
uh
uh you know some gun puppy or you know
you know he's just um he's a he's
someone who served he's someone who has
uh protected and served to the best of
his ability uh he spent 20 years on the
force or forces
um in the Los Angeles area uh we're
grateful for his time today just to
learn what it's like uh today's guest is
a detective and officer retired Mr Brad
White
[Music]
sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
dude thanks so much for your time man
absolutely yeah really really appreciate
it uh yeah I'm excited to learn about so
you've worked as police police detective
detective and an arc I was a Narcotics
no you were a narc I was in Narcotics
for a while oh dang bro dude they would
always accuse people of being narcs when
I was young yeah yeah yeah absolutely
it's 21 Jump Street yeah oh I remember
one time like we went in the woods to
smoke some weed or something and like
um it was like where you put the pin to
get the can and put the little holes in
the can and then you put the weed on
there absolutely and right when I went
to like hit it like uh I breathed out
for some reason or like kind of Snee or
like coughed and it blew all the weed
out of the bowl and just onto the ground
absolutely and people like you're a
[ __ ] Gnar you know people call me a
narc I think somebody yeah I think
somebody [ __ ] hit me in the back
um but anyway so uh so as an officer
we're going to get in uh like you've had
a pretty crazy career we're going to get
into it as an officer take me say if I
go on or like a ride along with you
right your first week on the job
we go on a ride along when you are a cop
okay what's that like
uh you're saying that it was my first
week yeah I'm just trying to put myself
like it right like right there in the
past okay
um well first off the first week of the
job the first time that they actually
put you out in the car by yourself you
know I was 21 years old so I remember
driving out of the parking lot and you
know getting ready to pull on that
street and I'm in full uniform you know
I got a shotgun I got a gun I got a
police car they're basically going out
saying going out and do what you got to
do and I remember the feeling of it just
going these people are [ __ ] nuts you
know this is crazy I'm 21 years old and
and you know I'm in this uniform and
they're literally sending me out to to
do what cops do so it takes a little bit
I remember at the starting it took it
took a while to get used to you know
it's a tremendous amount of power oh I
can't imagine it that reminds me of even
this when I got my first car and I'm
driving off I'm like okay I'm leaving
home I'm just it's me out here I can't
imagine if there's also weapons weapons
shotguns whole whole crew guys out there
with you they're gonna back up whatever
it is you do you know there's a it it's
pretty substantial for a young kid
especially at that age I can't even
imagine yeah too young 21's too young
yeah my belief is 21 is too young I
think I think there needs to be a little
bit you need to be a little further in
life but you know I mean they pull them
as early as 21. so wow so you're rolling
out there 21. you got the guns you got
the Weaponry you're cruising are you
like is there part of it is it
excitement too is it just fear what is
it uh you know there wasn't a lot of
fear a ton of adrenaline a ton of
excitement um you know you've already
gone through a long process the academy
where you've been you know gone through
a lot of training and seen a lot of
scenarios and heard a lot of stories so
uh you know when you first get out there
and you get on the streets uh it's it's
pure adrenaline I don't ever remember I
don't ever remember being initially
scared okay my fear wasn't really a
factor
it was just too big the group was too
big there was too much I mean you got a
gun for God's sake you know you're going
out on your own so what music do you
listen to like what song do you put on
that person yeah you know uh actually
none I didn't when I got into narcotics
when we would go to search warrants we
would always all the guys would wear you
know headsets on the way to the to the
location we always listen to our own
music I
I listened to uh for scenarios like that
I listened to Dan zigg mother I don't
know why but that was a big one for me
because his children yeah
just yeah just the lick itself but I
actually would listen to um My
Generation you know I would listen to a
lot of the Easy E six in the morning oh
yeah you know stuff like that stuff like
I yeah yeah
police at my door okay so you're out
there someone you're right on your first
week what's does it get kind of wild
your first week what's that like no it's
just getting used to it you know just
kind of figure out how it's done again
it's a tremendous amount of power and
and everything's new I mean I can
remember being 21 years old going to the
domestic violence calls and you know you
haven't even had any domestic violence
in your own life I didn't even have a
girlfriend yeah at that point I didn't I
didn't know anything about relationships
but you would go into these situations
where people were in turmoil you know
and there was real problems and they
would look at you and go you know what
are you gonna do what are we gonna do
and I remember thinking my mind like
well I got no [ __ ] clue you know
would you ever call your mom be like Mom
what should I even do no I never called
my mom I never call my mom now I
probably should have but you just kind
of wing it you know it's it's really
changed the way I look at everything
those scenarios because there was a real
expectation like I knew what I was doing
wow especially being young they just
because you're in that uniform they
think that you know what the next step
is as far as solving or the situation
and and you really don't for a long time
you wing it you know within the law
there's all kinds of statues and laws
that you all follow but when they start
asking for advice or or you know
it's crazy the expectation that you you
have a clear understanding of what to do
in any given situation wow and the
situations vary yeah so it must be crazy
so like a lot of times you were when you
encounter someone they need they're
having the worst day or it's their they
need help it's like the look in their
eyes it must always be one of like Panic
or fear or yeah generally you're dealing
with people's worst day no matter what
it was you're never going to a scenario
where people are happy and things are
going well it's always bad situations
even it's as simple as a ticket you know
for some people tickets are humongous
ordeal oh yeah dude you get a ticket
dude I remember I got three tickets
before I went to court for my first
ticket
so I got my first ticket I actually got
my first ticket on the way to being
sworn in in downtown L.A it's first time
I ever drove in downtown L.A and I made
an illegal U-turn I ended up getting a
ticket even showed the guy the paperwork
saying I'm getting sworn in I'm I'm one
of you guys he still wrote me a ticket
and we got to make those quotas yeah
that's what they say
um so tell me like one of the craziest
things that kind of happened out of the
gate like something that's kind of wild
um
the the first time I witnessed someone
die
um wow which is in 20 years there's been
quite a few of those um but the first
one I ever watched was a I got a radio
call I was very young I got a radio
calls in the LA area and it was with a
subject with a gun and they gave us a
description and when I pulled up the
location it was like a like a waffle not
a waffle house but like a chicken place
or something and I saw the guys out
front based on the description it was a
kid wearing a red puffer jacket
and as soon as I pulled up on the kid he
bolted so
um chase him a little bit with the car
as long as I could eventually he started
cutting through businesses and so on so
I'd go out on foot we had a foot pursuit
that went on for a little bit I chased
the guy through you know some parking
lots and so such and the kid ended up
running into the street I believe it was
me it was right at Manchester and
Gramercy and the kid ran right out into
the street without checking traffic and
he got hit by a car I was I don't know
20 30
then the probably not even that far
probably about 20 yards behind them so
it was right in front of me the he was
hit at full speed it was it was it was
brutal it was brutal the kid um he was a
mess you know and it was the first time
I ever witnessed someone die wow yeah so
and so are you at that point do you are
you still like in pursuit or at that
point it immediately you recognize oh
this is a bad attention now this has
changed
um there's just a lot of Dynamics to
that because there's a lot of civil when
you're a cop there's just a lot of civil
liability and no matter what you do you
know what I mean even in a scenario like
that when you're when you're going after
someone that has is in the commission of
a crime the fact that they're running
from you and you are chasing them it
puts you in some kind of civil liability
for it that that I realized at a later
time at that point because I was so
young
it was just it was overwhelming I mean I
couldn't even talk you literally had to
stop and and I lost my breath I remember
losing my breath and not being able to
to breathe for a second just because it
was just
it was incredible you know it probably
happened like that like that and it was
brutal and it was and you just you just
don't even know how to react you know
it's it's
unless people come out of their shoes
when they get hit like that yeah people
do come out of their shoes no way people
come out yes people come out of their
shoes people um I can traffic accidents
are probably some of the most simplistic
horrific things that you experience for
sure
and so when that guy gets hit do you
have to go render a then do you there
was no way to be rendered on this one
but yes yes I can give you a lot of
examples of having to render Aid in
situations that were
um you know an example being another
simple thing that you respond to a
drowning in a pool you know we I I went
one time to a kid that had drowned in a
pool and you want to talk about Panic
you want to talk about
um adrenaline is you get a radio call
they give you an address and I'm old
enough now I'm retired when I started
there was no Google Maps there was none
of that basically it came over a radio
you had a little pad of paper in the
middle of your car you wrote down the
address real quick you had a uh Thomas
guide yeah I remember that yeah [ __ ] and
50 000 page Thomas how many pages in
there and then someone somebody would
steal a page yeah well they wouldn't
steal them out of European right they
would stealing like a public life right
now I can't go to seven square blocks of
the city like even if I want to right
these ones we would mark up and tab okay
so that it was a little easier to access
okay you got a little bit of like filing
in there but you want to talk about
having a heart attack you know I'm
trying to find this and realize this is
a situation that's time is of the
essence but you you would get to these
you would you know lights and siren the
adrenaline's pumping you're going You're
hoping and making a wrong left turn or
something and finally getting to the
home
and in this scenario I'm telling you
about it was a child very young had
already been this it was deceased when I
got there for whatever reason Panic
whatever no one had gone into the pool I
think the scenario was the mother
couldn't swim
so she was on the uh the steps standing
there you know got rid of the equipment
I could jumped in the water got the baby
out of the baby was very obviously gone
um and but even in that scenario
I remember administering CPR just for
the Optics of it yeah you know just to
show I'm doing everything I can because
you want to talk about
pain and panic you know you talk you you
you you observe a mother which is
another thing that was that was frequent
in in
very difficult to deal with is watching
that pain and panic so I remember giving
CPR to a child that was clearly gone
until the fire department got there and
they usually take a while because we're
on the streets so we get there really
quick any 911 call comes in goes to the
police department they dispatch a cop
then they call the fire department and
they come because we're yeah and fire
department you got to get eight guys on
the truck it's so hard to get eight guys
to do anything you know if you've ever
been to Vegas or whatever you know it's
like you try to get guys to go do
anything it's like nearly impossible
um
wow man oh my God Brad there's so many
moments in there of like you've gotten
this child out of the pool you were like
now almost returning this child to the
mother in a way I mean physically you're
bringing you know like
the the they expect you to be able to
solve it is there any of that
essentially yes there's hope you know
but it's really it's the Optics it's
just I'm doing everything I can right
those kind of situations the panic and
the pain is so overwhelming and that's
something people don't take into
consideration in police work it happens
a lot there's a lot of I can tell you so
many scenarios like that where where you
know you're you're doing everything you
can even though you
there's just not a lot you can do right
you're just you're just a human yes and
but what they don't teach you at least
they didn't when I started
um in the Academy number one killer cops
of suicide really number one killer cops
is suicide they didn't have a gun yes so
you're halfway there if you want to gosh
guy we had a guy that was in the police
department right next to us
um I ended up getting into his car and
with his the duty shotgun blew his head
off right before he went out for the
shift was supposed to start but the
number one killer is cops they never
tell you that they never talk about
mental health I went through the entire
Academy they taught me how to
put on a tourniquet heal a sucking chest
wound they taught me so many things but
they never made one mention of how to
you know how to work with your own head
wow you know they never said suicide's
number one killer cops I think that's
changed I know it's changed but it's
getting a lot better
um but at that point there was no
mention of that and these things
accumulate I'm giving you
one portion of one day oh I can't
imagine especially like you know like I
grew up with a lot of childhood trauma
and um and a lot of people have right
and it's really common and
um and that is tough enough to deal with
in regular life as it comes up later and
you realize there's ways that it affects
you as an adult right yes I can't
imagine
um
whatever traumas you already have are
things that could have happened in your
past and then you're now just engulfed
in this you're like a do you feel like a
damn for trauma for people like do you
feel like a reciprocal for me yeah
because there's so many things and then
you just have to go on to the next call
is there
um it depends you know people don't take
it it's just there's no way to really
understand all the things that you
experience just in the shift right let
alone over a 20-year career especially
if you're working different assignments
I could tell you so many stories if you
could
ask questions I'll think of something
I'll tell you a story that Jules go like
holy cried you know from the simplest
thing of
uh I had a I had an old lady that was at
a church meeting at El Torito El Torito
in Whittier and she ended up collapsing
she had a heart attack
um and we got the call we get there and
by the time we got there there's a bunch
of old women that are in a circle and
they're oh y'all betting on her probably
well they're doing I think it was
they're doing tongues you know they're
uh praying in tongues and all kinds of
craziness going on but no one's doing
anything and I remember giving this lady
and at that point we had these
respirators where you could it's like a
bag with the thing goes over the face so
you don't have to put your mouth on them
well I had ran in and forgot it because
it was in the trunk so this is another
woman that I gave CPR going back to more
CPR stuff and she ended up vomiting in
my mouth where my mouth was on hers in a
way that it forced past my throat
so I vomited immediately when I came up
off of her on top of her
the entire scenario in itself now I
laugh about it when I tell the story
yeah
but it was just traumatic man the whole
thing was just for my late ended up
passing they transported stuff but the
whole situations I'm giving you minor
ones you know right well yeah I'm sure
she vomits into you you vomit into her I
mean I think that's a honor yeah that's
a wedding in some countries I feel like
you know I don't know what some of the
rituals are but I think if you're in
like Laos or something that you guys are
you guys are hitched uh but she she so
she came back at that moment and
survived for that moment uh fire
department got there apparently had a
pulse when she left so I was feeling
pretty good but I found at the end of
the shift that she had passed but um
there's so many so tell me give me a
call like give me the first call where
you have to go into a play like what's
it like when you have to walk up with
your weapon out that has to seem crazy
because then you're like saying okay I'm
in control it gives other people a sense
that you're in control of everything
um I guess it does things have changed
you know things have changed for law
enforcement when I first started I
started right at the right at the Rodney
King time okay that's that's right when
I started so when I got into law
enforcement and I I was a rookie
things were starting to change they were
you know people people want the World
Police they just don't want to know how
it's policed that's true and as with
technology there's come the ability to
see more of what policing is and at that
point with the Rodney King thing
things started started to change in law
enforcement they started to change the
process because police work was really
hard to look at
you know I mean and that dissemination
of that information wasn't very
prevalent because you didn't have
social media podcasts and all the
different things that we have now so
when I started it really started to
change as far as how we address things
you always hear people complain about oh
he gave me a traffic ticket when he
walked up to the car he had his hand on
his gun
you know and and that is that is just a
routine part of your training is that
you you have no idea what you're walking
up to you walk up to something you pull
someone over for speeding and you walk
to their car you have no idea what
you're walking up to you don't know who
it is you don't know what they've done
you know know where they came from you
have no idea what's going on yeah yeah
we had an officer that did a traffic
stop and there's a body in the trunk oh
wow you know he didn't even he gave the
ticket and left the only reason we found
that out is he got pulled over again
they found this ticket going this guy's
got pulled over an hour ago and they
ended up finding the body in the trunk
so the first guy didn't find the body no
oh no so the guy thought he got away but
he got pulled over again
um but the whole gun concept of it is is
things happen fast man these happen fast
you know you you you you'll die in a
hundredth of a second you know people
don't realize that that's how you put
your hands on on the steering wheel yada
yada all the the things that we say for
our safety and there's this expectation
by the public of if someone comes at you
with a baseball bat high as a kite
sweating shirt off crazy you know and
the expectation of the public is is well
you got to get a baseball bat and you
got to fight him with a baseball bat
right it's got to be fair you know you
you shot him all you had was a baseball
bat and for me guys that are cops you
hear that and you just go that's insane
do you really have an expectation me to
get a baseball bat fight yeah you know
I'm not here the only thing a cop's
trying to do is trying to stop the
situation he's trying to eliminate the
threat right if there's some dude roving
around with a baseball bat I think you
gotta take him out the game
depending on the scenario like anybody
if you're in your home and someone
breaks into your home you still have
enough someone breaks in your home in
the middle of night today you still have
an obligation to prove that you were in
fear for your life
wow so if there's some guy standing in
your bedroom and you wake up and you
look and there's a guy standing there
and you grab your gun and you eliminate
the threat you're still going to go to
court and they're still going to try to
prove that you were not in fear for your
life
who's going to try to prove that is that
more lawyers or is that more the actual
criminal because he doesn't want to go
to jail
um it's going to go it's just the whole
process it's gonna go to the detective
detectives can take it to the district
attorney District Attorney's gonna take
a look at make a decision is this
something that we is good did this guy
violate the law was he justified was he
justified shooting this individual so in
that process they'll look at it you know
where was he shot was he shot in the
back was he shot
which there's an argument for that
someone breaks into your house you see
them you're scared they take off running
you chase after them with a gun
and you end up shooting at them and the
living room as they're going back to
work
you're all sudden you're up for murder
it's a good point you know yeah and and
there's the whole thought process of
that is I don't want this guy to leave
what if he comes back I'll never be able
to sleep again you know what I mean
there's no justification on your part
it's clear this holiday season you know
if you're looking for a new gift that uh
that will inspire somebody and help
broaden their life and Branch their life
out verbally then you want to look at
Babel that's right Babel is the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million co uh subscriptions and that's a
lot think of 10 million people learning
something and think of it being a
language and Bam that's babble
with Babel you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you can start
having a real life conversations in a
new language in as little as three weeks
with Babel you can choose from 14
different long washes including Spanish
French Italian and German plus Babel's
speech recognition technology helps you
improve your pronunciation and accent
right now get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to
babbel.com Theo that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash t-h-e-o for up to
55 off your subscription Babble language
for life you know I waste money on
different subscriptions I notice
you know I got a subscription the other
day I realized I accidentally subscribed
to it was like Sherman's uh shoestrings
or something and they start sending it
uh separate pairs of strings you know
shoe strings just you know you got dang
you know I got 90 feet of shoe strings
at the house now and I don't know what
to do and I don't know how to
unsubscribe that's the problem
I'm wasting money on subscriptions like
that
you know eighty percent of people have
subscriptions they forgot about it could
be an unused uh Amazon Prime account or
a Hulu account that never gets streamed
and that adds up that's why you need to
check out rocket money
it's the app that shows all your
subscriptions in one place and cancels
what you don't want
rocket money can even find subscriptions
you didn't know you were paying for
you may you may even find out you've
been double charged for a subscription
to cancel a subscription all you have to
do is press cancel and Rocket money
takes care of the rest
that's right right now cancel
unnecessary subscriptions with rocket
money today go to rocketmoney.com
t-h-e-o
seriously it could save you hundreds per
year that's
rocketmoney.com
Theo now can we carry guns in California
if you have a CCW okay yeah how do we
know if we have that or not you have to
get it it's like a license it's like a
fishing license you know a little more
complex California's tough California is
tough to get a CCW you go to Texas it's
a lot easier yeah and the logic behind
that is
um like I personally believe I know the
big debate right now is guns no guns get
rid of guns ships best ship has sailed
right
right and if we did do that we said
bring all your guns in the only guys
that bring their guns are guys like me
yeah you know the bad guys ain't
bringing their cars no so that ship is
completely sailed so the idea for me is
I feel like we need more guns I think we
need more guns and good people's hands
wow so how do you know then do you like
do like how wouldn't you say good people
and do we need all types of guns like
you see these young kids or you know a
lot of these School shooters you see
people getting guns like these uh
high-powered rifles and stuff I for me I
feel like if you haven't served
with that gun like militarily I feel
like you shouldn't be able to have
access to that gun right like because at
least then there's some you're at least
putting in the hands maybe of someone
that has some semblance of a purpose
knows how to use it I guess I don't know
for some reason that helps me a little
bit think about that kind of stuff but
to think that like someone needs an
assault rifle like a 20 year old it just
seems that seems crazy to me you know
what it does to me too I I'm not I'm not
a gun guy
um since I retired I've got some guns
that my dad had since he's passing the
safe I got my one gun I carried on duty
I don't have any more uh obviously a lot
of cops are gun guys a lot of guys have
AR-15s you know you name it mp5s all the
way down I don't I don't see the
necessity for them again you're going
back to the problem the problem is is we
can't get rid of them because all we'll
be doing is taking them from the good
people right and now we got a whole
bunch of and when I say bad people
just people that would use that gun
in a negative way right you know in the
commission of crimes or whatever so
again that ship has sailed I I'm not a
hunter I can't imagine killing anything
I even have a hard time fishing you know
I just I'm I'm not that guy
but their justification always is
hunting is it necessary no but I mean
it's a waste of time the ship sailed you
know we just have to deal with what we
have now there's no collecting guns not
in this country yeah I agree it seems um
it just seems almost like a Battle Cry
that people it almost seems like people
didn't use it to just incite like it's a
nice dream yes but it's just unrealistic
and also this country was kind of
founded on somebody pulling a gun on
somebody didn't have a gun I feel like
maybe I don't know I wasn't there but if
like like troops pulled the guns on the
Indians and then I just wonder how much
of that really goes over through time
too you know well I think the big
argument for gun nuts is is that it's
the government you know I mean to never
allow that situation to happen again
where this power that is policing us
that makes sense too can inflict their
will on us well that makes sense too
especially now with like social media
platforms like people you can't even say
certain things yes so people's voices
have really been I'm not saying they've
been deceased because we have a voice
here today but they've certainly been
corralled
um and earmarked with expectations I
feel like uh so at that point you can
have a really tough time if people don't
even have their voice anymore to take
people's guns you're just gonna have a
tough time doing it it's just a
conversation it's a waste of time right
it's like it's it's all it's across the
board all those conversations the the
big conversation now and racism wouldn't
that be wonderful if we could end racism
but we're never going to yeah it's
always going to be here so we need to
that cry needs to change it needs to be
of individual accountability that's the
only that is the only path that we have
is individual accountability yeah you
know there's always going to be bad
people you know yeah what is that is
that your phone or mine yeah it is it's
okay do you need it to be on no I don't
know a few minutes ago it made that
sound it made me nervous I thought I had
a damn Life Alert bracelet so that I
forgot about Life Alert
um so tell me this tell me about let's
we'll get back into some of this stuff
man and it's really interesting and
thank you so much for for sharing your
inside information and just some of your
Insight you know pleasure
um so taking on some of the drug stories
because that's the part that seems kind
of crazy and we ever roll up on some
people and they're just yacked out of
their brain bro and it's that late night
hour you know maybe just some hookers
lurking or something like because I've
been there myself so I'm just wondering
how we I've never had it where the cops
show up you know so I'm just wondering
what there's that weird Edge though
where you're like damn a cop you know
I've had um
in narx and out of Narcotics I'll give
you a patrol one uh very early on middle
of the day I remember it was hot it was
summer we got a call about a individual
in the middle of an intersection naked
so uh we drive down to the intersection
and we're talking about a busy busy I I
started in South Central busy
intersection
middle of the day
huge huge dude in the middle of the
intersection butt naked covered in sweat
damn going in circles which was causing
in the middle of the intersection people
to slow as they were going through so
what he was doing as they slowed he
would run up to their car and try to
dive through their window or break the
window out oh wow and people would panic
and take off and leave
um this was back when I started and PCP
was a big deal Los Angeles yeah and
based on what I saw that's pretty common
guys on PCP to shed their clothes and
was it a uh was that more of a drug some
drugs are for certain are used more in
certain communities was it more of a
black community drug a white community
drug is it more of a poor drug a rich
drug
um
Buzz black community Hispanic Community
again I can't I can't I know that's not
definitive but yeah but the problem with
that for me to tell you I'll tell you
what it was and that's what I
experienced the neighbors but I I
started in a black community I was in
South Central and I moved on to Whittier
which was a Hispanic community so those
are the and there was Whittier was a
little more mixed but predominantly
Hispanic so my interpretation of any of
this is just what I experienced I can't
tell you much more oh I see what you're
saying got it so yes it was very
prevalent in the black community at that
time they used to smoke shrooms yeah
that's what I would hear I've seen it on
movies and stuff they would feature that
on movies I remember crazy wow that [ __ ]
was crazy and that [ __ ] really died off
it died off quick by the time remember
they marching or dancing was there any
kind of like fluidity to it was it like
capoeira kind of or was it like just
like a maniac like a wrestler coming
into the ring like was there any [ __ ]
maniacs wow yeah completely totally out
of control completely and totally being
for being conscious they were totally
incoherent wow there was no reason with
them and they were extraordinarily
strong that drug would bring out
extraordinary strength yeah so when we
pulled up and I recognized as I saw
there obviously there was a situation
where there was a
threat to the public because this guy's
trying to get into cars and people are
still trying to pass they're still
trying to go through the intersection
even though there's this naked you know
dude in the middle of it so what I end
up doing is just driving around this guy
in circles clearing this actually with
my lights and siren on and all that
noise and lights and the confusion kind
of kept him in the middle it kept him in
the middle he would walk a little bit
but I would I kept doing these circles
and tell more police officers got there
and the good thing about Los Angeles is
that when you call for help there's so
many neighboring police agencies
sheriffs LAPD yada yada that they're
there quick and a lot and we had a lot
of police officers quick so we end up
doing is getting out of the car and kind
of circling this guy well now it's on
because there's not a lot that we can do
and this is back in the day when we
didn't have a lot of really efficient
less than lethal stuff right I mean they
used to issue saps which is crazy sap is
a it's a it's a little clether Club
bring it up Zach let's look at it yeah
it's a little leather club that has sand
in it that sole purpose was just to beat
on somebody wow and they police uniforms
had a little pocket in the back of the
leg and you put the sap in there they
even had sap gloves where you put them
on and have the sand thing which Looking
Back Now yeah there's all kinds of
different examples of a sap those things
hurt yeah those things are brutal and
they're Compact and they were very
effective if they were using the right
scenario it totally outdated they're
totally gone now we've found much better
ways
um to address situations but back in the
day that's what they gave you and how
long was it how long is this like a
couple feet oh okay you know something
you can carry on yeah but standard issue
even then it went to the Baton yeah some
people still care baton's becoming
extinct because the Baton is just it's
just the dynamic of the way it looks
being used it's just ugly oh yeah yeah I
agree the Optics of it the Optics is
tough and my friend Chad got a job after
Katrina they were hiring anybody to be
security right because they needed you
know everything was unsecure and
he only weighed probably 95 pounds or
something he was small I think he's like
a premature baby or something or I don't
know if he was premature he was kind of
immature but he was I guess he was
premature or whatever but he would
probably he probably had seven months on
him you know Jeff stating you know and
so when he said when they gave him that
billy club it weighed him down so much
yeah just because of how strong he was
at after like a week it had like almost
dislocated his hip just walking around
so he had to quit yeah but um that's a
tool that died really after Rodney King
they still have them they still carry
them they still train a lot of them but
it's just bad Optics yeah the Optics of
that went down after that okay so go on
so anyways we we got this guy's Circle
Bowl in the china shop man yeah yeah
this guy is nut so now the situation is
is that you know again police work a lot
even back then it's Optics right you
know we everyone's watching you right
now so you you not only have the dynamic
of I'm dealing with a guy and if I
remember him he was big and I'm a big
guy and I remember this guy was big and
it was just intimidating and as high as
a kite sweating and he's growling in the
whole thing so this is this is not going
to be a simple situation again didn't
have the tasers we didn't have
we didn't have those things what about a
net didn't have a net didn't have
there's a lot of less and lethal stuff
that they're introducing now that we
just didn't have it back then you know
and and I guess it was because it's like
anything it's Evolution right you don't
need it till you need it or you don't
need it until whatever you had before is
no longer socially acceptable right
Rodney King pretty much killed the Baton
it really did huh it really did and and
it's it's not a bad thing yeah you know
they found better ways but we didn't
have it back then so now the situation
was how so we're gonna have to bum rush
this guy we're all gonna have to go go
in and get this guy I actually had this
scenario twice well in police work the
newest guys get the worst assignments
you know unfortunately in that scenario
right there it was a lot of age
different agencies so everyone didn't
know so
I remember the sergeant pointing out
guys that were obviously new
and
they essentially rushed this guy who's
completely naked on a hundred plus
degree day on the asphalt in the middle
of an intersection in Los Angeles and it
was on wow man I mean it was on for a
while and then then once one guy got
into the ground and everyone gets in and
even when you have you can only have so
many people involved just because of the
space Factor yeah I mean and even with
having five six seven eight nine guys on
this guy I it took 15 20 minutes to get
him in custody you know to actually get
his hands behind us back and get
handcuffs on right by the time that
shit's done you're covered in all kinds
of [ __ ] yeah I'm sure you know what I
mean you've been out there yeah you're
good yeah and especially when you guys
all go running at him I bet it's like
it's almost like spin the bottle like
the last thing you want to get is the
guy who runs right you know straight at
his wiener exactly be honest totally the
other scenario having that to make it
real quick we had a guy that we got to
call uh someone saw a guy looking
through their win a little girl saw guy
looking through a window oh man keeping
Tom
essentially we get to the house we get
there she shows us the window we find
the window below the window there's
semen oh so this guy had been looking
through the window at the little girl
and and you know doing doing his his
business yeah masturbating there you go
and so we we ended up looking for the
guy we ended up finding him in some
bushes not too far away again white guy
creepy tall totally naked yeah and his
testicles were the size of a softball
and purple
and what we what we later found out is
he had tied a kite string around the
base of his balls and for some reason
that did something for him but what it
did do is it made his balls really swell
up yeah it was visible so you got a guy
that's completely sweaty he's not coming
out of the bushes you see he's got big
giant purple testicles that something's
wrong
again god of the officers there circled
it but at that point I was the youngest
this was just our Police Department so
they'd go on in go on in there get this
guy out so what I had to spend about
five minutes wrestling a dude that's
naked with big giant purple balls and a
kite string around it dripping in sweat
while all my peers and friends were
around me pointing and laughing
literally it was crazy it was crazy and
then at the end of it when I booked him
in I had to cut the string off oh come
on can't put him in the jail cell with
that on like it's a grand opening or
something yeah yeah yeah I actually had
to cut the string off and book it in as
evidence oh man and did those nuts
subside once you took that string off
him uh I don't remember I don't remember
that was the last that was the only
visual I was trying not to deal with you
know I remember it being very difficult
to get those scissors in there you know
oh cut that thing off can't give him
scissors and tell him to do it it's a
situation where you just can't do that
booking people is booking people was
tough yeah I had a homeless guy that I
booked
um and you have to do a strip search on
everybody no oh yeah you can't put them
in the cell can't put them in the cell
without doing a strip search you gotta
make sure they don't have anything
that's gonna hurt themselves or others
with so every single guy that that you
arrest
you you essentially see the crack of
their ass oh you see them naked you know
I had a homeless guy where guy I'm naked
and squat and cough and when he squat we
haven't turned the opposite way we have
him squat we have him cough and spread
their butt cheeks to make sure they
don't have anything in their butt oh
yeah and he had heroin balloons all
matted up in his ass hair hmm
where he had obviously put him in there
to hide him oh yeah you know they're
little colorful balloons that's how they
would do the store the heroin they put
it inside the plate of balloons so we
told him take you know you need to pull
those out you pull those out and the guy
wouldn't do it you know [ __ ] you you do
it you get him out which is a great move
on his part at that point I was a rookie
so I had the assignment of pulling
getting butt uh heroin balloons out of
this dude's butt hair damn that's that
Colombian birthday party dude yeah yeah
that's crazy man have you ever had to
get uh how much drugs can people put in
their butt
I guess that depends on who it is we had
a guys that tried to end the jail he
keistered a uh racquetball which he had
slid open and put the drugs inside of it
and then put it up his butt a racket
ball what is it a racquetball you know a
racquetball is like this little smaller
tennis ball racquetball you know
racquetball yeah I'm thinking about it's
just not registered they're blue rubber
oh yeah a little bit into his butt got
in his butt wow yeah that's relatively
that's I think that's not relatively too
big from I've seen guys with Coke
bottles that they put in their guy put a
coke bottle in his butt but he it was it
was open it was an open Coke bottle but
when he put in for the suction when he
tried to pull it out he couldn't get it
out oh it formed a suction issue so we
had to transport this guy to the G to
the hospital to have it in an emergency
room surgically removed oh man that'll
make it switch to Pepsi huh but also
that's like that sir Galahad or
something what's the one where they try
to pull the thing out of there yeah
Sword in the Stone yeah it's like Sword
in the Stone yeah pretty humiliating
situation tough ride to the hospital I
fell for the guy you know and you can't
sit down that's got to be the worst
thing you keep thinking you can sit down
and then every time
humiliating imagine having to walk into
an emergency room you know yeah to get a
coke bottle removed from your yeah and
you have to kind of walk in like kind of
yeah I would probably yeah and if it's
glass huh it's glass oh that's so risky
yeah God it's almost like that it's like
um don't wake the baby or one of those I
feel like it has like a real game show
element too yeah that is the most
Japanese game show element to it I've
ever heard you know I feel like it's the
thing about police work that people
don't realize is that you're
it's this is the craziest [ __ ] you know
it's just you don't realize that people
don't realize that they don't even think
about it they watch the movies there's
an infatuation with police work you
watched all these movies that you see
none of them none of them really there's
a few there's a show called The
Southland which actually one of our
officers wife was a in in the business
and she was somehow involved and and you
could tell that someone knew about
police work was involved but when you
watch like
training day and you know all the other
stuff they're great entertainment but
people think that's real yeah they don't
know what it's really like you know
that's why these opportunities for
someone like me to come and I have no
ties I'm retired I don't even
I want to do guys right that are in the
job this gives me an opportunity to to
explain you know this is what's really
like
so there's an out I mean doesn't you
just don't you any day it could be
absolutely anything like it's like the
levels of things
it almost feels too vast it is it is
it's everyday it was I loved the job by
the time I got out I had to get out
because it just it where your life
changes I start I had a child and you
know seeing dead children
um just all the different things that
you experience as life goes on it starts
it starts to wear you it starts to beat
you down that's that's why cops retire
at 50. it's it's you got to get out
mentally you got to get out it's just
too much it's too much the physical
aspect's not that big of a deal but the
mental is you see everything I I mean I
can tell you gosh I could tell you what
about a jumper you get a jumper
no there was nowhere where I was in
Whittier there was nothing that high oh
yeah yeah Winter's pretty flat I had um
I had a here's a crazy scenario that we
dealt with we had a call middle of the
night of a female bleeding profusely we
got to the house and this dude answers
the door and he is a tweaker I mean this
guy as high as a kite stereotypical oh
yeah [ __ ] Radio Shack manager totally
shirt off tripping out
just came back probably collecting
copper on his bike and how did they
answer the doors and always like is
there one common way that Tweakers
answered the door like what's up no not
really they don't answer the door
usually they just you see the blinds
open a little bit bam you know you can
see okay they're inside but this guy
answered the door because he needed us
okay the situation was is that he was
with his girlfriend and they were both
high zakai it's like four in the morning
and when we walked in she's laying on
the floor in the living room and there's
blood everywhere oh there's blood all
over her legs and she's holding an old
nasty t-shirt on her crotch and this
t-shirt is pretty saturated so when we
start talking to this guy in his you
know in his tweaker way he starts to
explain to us that they were
being an emit intimate and um during
that they had gotten a dildo a really
large
purple dildo and he had taken a coat
hanger on those old school Metals coat
hangers and he had unwounded you know
how when you like if you're doing I'll
cook it marshmallows cooking
marshmallows how you do that well he
essentially made like that but he took
the end of that the Pokey end and he
stuck it into the ends of the the dildo
and then he bent that coat hanger so it
was a handle so he was using that on his
girlfriend right so he was really he was
going yeah he was getting in there and
doing what he could yeah yeah he was he
was making it happen trying to jump
start that cooch yeah yeah so what ended
up happening was is those Pokey ends
ended up coming through the side of the
dildo so when he was doing it he was
essentially cheese grating her insides
bro I that my I feel like right now my
[ __ ] hurts oh yeah it does to this day
to this day it bothers me I don't even
have a [ __ ] right to this day it hurts
me you know but so when he described and
when he held that we said where is it
where's the item and when he went and
got it and held it up there was
literally tissue there was tissue that
was on the thing so this was bad this is
a situation it was bad but yeah yeah
that's about as bad as it gets right
yeah do you press like uh
is it like a butt do you press when it
gets too bad no who do you call when it
gets too bad you know what you end up
doing when it gets too bad or cops have
been doing they end up [ __ ] joking
about it wow they end up it's a coping
mechanism man and it and it it just
happens and I can remember in that
scenario the hardest part in that star I
had been on for quite a while and the
guy I was with had been on for quite a
while as well in that specific scenario
the hardest part for us was not to start
laughing wow you know because it was
right it was just so [ __ ] crazy it
was just so crazy standing in the living
room yeah with two Tweakers one's blink
profusely he's holding up it's got
tissue
the other problem was is that we have we
have a responsibility to render Aid yeah
you know civil liability is a big deal
when you're a cop at any given time you
can lose everything because you fail to
follow one part of your job description
rendering Aid is one of them so I
remember looking at the guy who had less
time on me with side going now you know
what the [ __ ] you got to do right you
got to apply pressure man and he's got
to do it because he's younger he's
younger yeah you got well he less time
on it yeah he so I was and
that conversation looking at your buddy
and saying look at you you got to do
this man
the the difficulty and not laughing in
that situation the both of you like your
face and him look at me and going
there's no [ __ ] way there's just no
[ __ ] way I'm gonna do this dude and
you're going no you have to do this WOW
luckily we we were able to we were
having such a hard time dealing with not
laughing that it went on just long
enough that we heard sirens and it was a
fire department you know and at that
point it's like yeah this is all you
guys man you guys dude that's so
interesting so there must be such bonds
kind of that are formed out there
between cops are there
yeah
um because I would just feel you're
going through such insane situations you
know and it's so interesting that you
guys use humor to cope because it's the
same thing it's the same thing why a lot
of comedians get into things you know
things were traumatic or some type of
way and so they used humor to survive
you know I think it's amazing that
mother nature uses that as like a uh
like a governor on us you know yeah
where it's like if you get so far you
just laugh I think it's why the Joker
laughs in the Joker movies because at a
certain point he's just so mad yeah that
oh there's nothing left to do but laugh
at it you know pretty much the
situations are so outrageous and like
you said as far as the bonds
please please there is strong bonds and
and I'm married love my wife we've been
together for 20 years we talk about
everything my best friend my entire
career I never went home and I never
discussed anything with her
literally never discussed any there was
never a good time to come home and say
Hey you know I saw a [ __ ] kid died
today you know all the things that went
on during the day unless it was like
really light I never told her anything
traumatic wow because she's it's just
never a good time you know why would I
want her to experience these these
especially as time goes on these
horrific things so the only people you
do talk about that with are these guys
that you're doing it with and nine times
out of ten when you do talk about it
later it's just it feels so
inappropriate because you're it becomes
a joke right the most horrific
situations
they become funny you know and it and
anyone else that hears that it's it is a
hard pill to swallow you know it's a
hard for the general public to go why
the [ __ ] are they laughing right you
know what's so funny you'll see
sometimes on TV I'll see like homicide
scenes on TV and I'll and I'll I'll look
at because I'm conscious I'm aware of
this I'll look at the officers around
and you do it for now on you'll see
every once in a while you'll see two
guys and they'll be horrific murder
scene shootings whatever and there's be
two [ __ ] cops right there and they'll
be laughing wow you know they'll be
communicating to be laughing and you go
like oh dude that's such bad Optics that
such but you totally understand it right
you know the rest of the world doesn't
wow yeah another night of Epic fights is
here it's time to fist up
it's time to stay fisting baby
I'm talking about UFC 282 it's an
action-packed Fight Card my boy Bryce
Mitchell is going to be on there he's
been a two-time guest here on the pod
I'll be throwing down on this one with
DraftKings sports book the official
sports betting partner of UFC
so check this out right now if you like
to gamble and you can do it safely
that everyone can earn up to a 50 boost
when you place a same game parlay on UFC
282
download the app now use promo code
t-h-e-o bet five dollars pre-fight money
line on any fighter to win and get one
hundred and fifty dollars in free bets
if they do that's code Theo this
Saturday at DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of UFC
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details well
baldness people are going bald look out
of your window what's happening baldness
I saw a dang cat the other day and he
was damn balded out Jesus
that's why keeps can help you
keeps
there are only two FDA approved
modifications that can prevent hair loss
and keeps offers them both
convenient virtual consultations with a
licensed medical provider and
medications delivered straight to your
door every three months that's keeps you
don't have to leave your home
God imagine staying in your home getting
better hair and finally coming out when
you're haired up I mean you gonna be
dang haired up
Bigfoot's gonna Sasquatch will be out
there
wanting to know what conditioner you're
using
that's right keep says everything your
hair needs delivered straight to your
door with discreet packaging and proven
results if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s.com slash t-h-e-o to receive
your first month of treatment for free
that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Theo to get your
first month free keeps.com slash Theo
dude there's so much pressure on you
guys like
how what was that kind of like what has
that been like like the pressure that
here's a young man
who didn't grow up with any amazing or
special skills
um
and now they're
in charge of
kind of being a jury at certain times
being like immediate aid going into
something they don't really know what's
going on half the time that person is
required or expected to have all these
answers
you know and they have these tools on
their belt that some of them are lethal
that they're supposed to use I
Jesus man there's there's a tremendous
amount of training that cops get as far
as all the stuff that you have and how
to use it
um as far as as far as the pressure like
I told you earlier you know number one
killer of cops is suicide yeah people
have always wanted people want to go to
bed at night and close their eyes and
feel they're safe that's the only reason
we all sleep at night because we think
there's people out there that are
keeping us safe you know there is a
that's a really good point isn't it it
is the second that the police are gone
somebody in your house is going to have
to be at your window which is the
craziest part of what's going on lately
it's hard to watch I've escaped it you
know even after Rodney King there was a
push and I'm down for the push I'm down
for everything always getting better we
can in any in any facet we can get
better we can do this better but this is
a very complex job that you can't
you can't identify everything you're
going to come in in contact with there's
no way to be ready for everything that
happens no there's just no possible way
in this job right and
a large portion of these things that
you're coming in contact with are life
and death you know their their moment
they're they're brutal you know our mom
walking with her child and saw a car
coming it was going to run the red light
and she jumped back in the thing and
lost her
well lost her grip on him and he got hit
and sucked up into the wheel well and
you know you get there and there's no
there is no way to properly handle that
situation you know I mean there is no
there's nothing that can be done and
people don't under understand that
aspect of police work you know they ask
a lot of police what I when I watch what
was happening when I watch those videos
of what was going on and you see it you
saw it spray painted all over the acab
all cops are bad are you talking about
during BLM are you talking about yes
okay yes all cops are bad you know and I
and it was everywhere and there was just
this the concerted push of demonizing a
million people
and we we've never really we have done
that but we don't really do that to any
other profession like we do cops yeah
there's a there's a there's a
ton of bad doctors
oh horrible ton of bad doctors just
writing prescriptions dude I used to
catch them all the time man Fishers they
would just what do you want
150 oxy here you go I'm just killing
people left and right you know moral is
all for money
we've never had a concerted effort of of
demonizing doctors because the world
feels like we need doctors but they
don't feel that way about police how
they were saying get rid of the cops
yeah that was insane insane one of the
reasons why I moved over to I bought a
house in Nashville about a year and a
half ago just because I I was pretty
sure it was a place where people could
carry weapons on their own
so I just wanted there to be
I don't know I know that there's people
that like to hunt and I would rather
have some of them be around sure in case
things get or at least somebody you know
somebody rolls into a diner you know
with a you know losing you know with a
weapon there's going to be seven other
guys in there absolutely we're gonna
find a way to finish their [ __ ] eggs
that morning which is I've been talking
about earlier you know I believe that we
need more it's the only solution we need
more guns and more good people's hands
at all times more ccw's you know I
really truly believe that's what is CCW
concealed weapons license yeah yeah
Arkansas weapon yeah I I I I that's the
thing well it's funny because it's not
even that is I never even consciously
made that choice really I just said okay
I need to be in a place where I know
that someone around me
can have a weapon yes and I can if I
need to yes yeah it was just a it was
almost like a subconscious Choice really
yes
um which is the issue with you know the
the way the community the way they've
this concerted effort there's all kinds
of reasons why it occurred which of
course none of us want to get in but
this effort to demonize these good
people I'll be honest man I I'm not I'm
I'm I did police work for 20 years
it doesn't occupy me I don't care I
don't have a gun on me right now I don't
carry a gun because I feel like I don't
need to
police work is not
does not define me but some of the best
people I've ever met were cops yeah just
really saw and we came from all
different places my me how I got there
was much different than the way most got
we were totally opposite yeah there is a
lot of guys that you see you know like
they probably got their ass kicked
through high school and became cops
but I found the majority of those guys
they were good dudes there was guys that
weren't you know but within police
departments especially now they really
police themselves and and contain or get
rid of those people they don't want that
either right and a lot of cops are just
really solid solid human beings and and
the world just recently they tried to
turn on them in their entirety they did
exactly what they said that the uh that
is happening to other people they
completely stereotyped a million people
yeah it's crazy right right they yeah
it's like people saying don't stereotype
but then we're gonna stereotype this
huge group of people that are keeping us
safe and now we're less safe than we've
ever been are we really I was going to
ask you that are we less safe than we've
ever absolutely the whole idea of police
work when I started the whole idea of
police work in its entirety was
proactive policing man get out there and
find crime before it occurs I want you
to shake cars I want you to shake cars
means pull them over find out what's
going on find out what they got up there
I want you to Frisk tickle yes and
there's a whole dynamic to that that's
always in debate of like oh he stopped
me because of this or he stopped me
because of that which is it's it's
really not true but it's too long of an
explanation for that but the whole idea
of police work was is to find the crimes
before they occurred and now what has
happened with what the demonizing of
police and the way that they have
unfairly attacked them like I said the
expectation is of oh man he only had a
baseball bat and you shot him right you
know it's like what are you talking
about like this wasn't even a
conversation that was stomped down back
in the day that wasn't allowed to go
very far because that's ridiculous right
but now guys are losing their jobs
they're not just losing their jobs
they're going to jail so now literally I
still have my a good friend of mine is
the chief of the police department that
I worked at now and they're literally
telling police officers and essentially
I only want you to deal with what we
have to deal with so cops aren't out
there doing proactive policing anymore
they're not out there actively looking
for stuff because they're literally
scared that no matter what they do the
world's going to turn on them based on
a video clip yeah you know or a
concerted effort once that video clip is
seen of all these people in high power
positions to have the venue to
disseminate all this information to turn
on them and say this guy did this I can
give you so many examples which I'm not
but of P of cops being unjustifiably
tried and convicted really on television
on television wow you know where they've
said this guy is a bad person and look
at what he did
yeah take me through one that's
interesting do you because I agree with
you I agree it's impossible how do you
get all of the how do you say all of
these people and I wasn't one of the
people who jump on that you know I'm the
one of the ilk that it's like yeah maybe
there's some bad guys here maybe there's
some people that are untrained or not
trained well but I'm not I have always
felt like I've had a decent relationship
with police unless I was doing something
wrong and in that time I didn't have the
best time with them you know and nobody
wants to be held accountable even a
housewife that gets pulled over for
speeding I mean I've had I've had women
that look like mothers
completely lose their [ __ ] on me wow
just over a ticket just completely
unreasonable screaming yelling cussing
don't you got anything [ __ ] better to
do you know there's crimes going on and
yeah and that's just such an ignorant
statement to you know we have to enforce
all laws you know there's reasons all
laws are in place but
yeah
the I'm trying to think of one recently
I don't know if you remember this there
was a there was a scenario right after
the um the big incident that occurred um
where I think it was like in Atlanta or
something it was two cops and they were
trying to take this guy into custody and
it was a drag out fight it was they had
the whole clip I mean they were fighting
and the guy ended up the suspect ended
up taking the guy's taser remember and
he ran and he turned back and he shot
the taser towards the cops okay
that guy's done there's just that's that
guy is unequivocally the justification
for a police officer to eliminate that
threat is 100 100 unequivocal
because if you are a person take if you
are a person a job a cop's job is to
identify a crime to take that person
into custody and to take them to before
a judge and to have them processed for
the crime they're not there to
administer punishment I think that's
where the problem with some cops get
some cops get so
somebody spits on your face it's hard
not to react yeah
I've had that my my name is Brad white
my name tag said be white when I worked
in South Central I had a guy actually
come up to me and we were involved in a
scenario where I was investigating crime
and he noticed my name tag and he
decided to go on a tangent about it I
see how a [ __ ] is Officer B white you
know and didn't even register with me
but I'm like oh [ __ ] no my name is Brad
man you know my name is Brad dude right
you're missing the rad part yeah yeah
yeah dude I I actually got my name tag
changed because of it I just didn't want
to deal with that sure yeah I just
didn't want to deal with that again sure
dude but in in this in the scenario that
you saw with those those two Atlanta
cops I mean there's just
those guys that guy decided that he was
not going to jail right and he was going
to do anything he needed not to go to
jail and that cop's job is he can't just
go okay [ __ ] it you know you don't want
to go I'll see you later because now
that guy loses his job he has to take
this individual custody there is no
there is no not doing it right because
now if that guy goes and does something
immediately down the street done civil
liability civil liability in the cops
are sued cops are sued people lose trust
in the police department it's just it's
a it's a very difficult Dynamic so those
guys had no choice at that point but
they take this guy into custody and and
when you're in a fight like that when
you're in a fight where someone's
fighting a cop I remember when I was a
little kid man I knew if I run from the
cops I'm getting my ass beat yeah that's
just how it used to be you know I mean
that's how it was that's my
understanding of what it was but if this
guy is doing all of this to get away
he's capable of anything when you're in
a fight like that as a cop your thought
process is if this guy overwhelms me
he's gonna get my gun and I'm done yeah
it's over so immediately when someone
starts really truly resisting you
physically a cop's in a fight for his
life
and the public doesn't understand that
right if you're fighting a cop you're
going to do whatever it's necessary
you've already just you've already
demonstrated across that line already
crossed that line I'm gonna do whatever
it needs to get away so at that point
you're going to fight for your life so
those cops were so Justified even though
that guy was running away they started
to chase him when that guy turned and
shot that taser at them there's no
the probability of them knowing that
that was a taser is minimal yeah
absolutely minimal and they put that on
TV and they demonize those two guys
without any kind of a hearing or any
true information whatsoever and it was
Criminal
it was criminal but that goes on a lot
and if you notice you never heard about
that again
because they they put that to rest
because that was totally justified and
all the powers that be that wanted to
use that for their agenda they even left
it alone because it became pretty
evident really quick once people started
looking at it going like what are they
supposed to do you know what is the
scenario that's supposed to happen there
well and so how bad is the media in all
of this how about how much have they
become because you know it's funny like
it doesn't even seem sometimes like the
government is the government anymore it
seems like the government is this
[Music]
um
LLC kind of of or Americas like this LLC
of just like corporations and capital
interests and that media kind of
controls a lot of stuff I mean how scary
is it to you guys because the meaty
somebody puts out a clip some uh some
group uses it to kind of push their
narrative or something like that
um and then you got and then police are
like
what are we supposed to do you know it
almost doesn't leave you a place to do
anything you know is the media like does
it sometimes feel like the media is not
on your side
um yeah man you're going into a whole
thing recently that just seems like it's
to be such a drawn-out topic but yeah
what's going on now I never really dealt
with again I I never had a scenario
where it was so high profile that I was
dealing with the media on a personal
level and have all knowledge of exactly
what happened
um but it does it it definitely appears
like the media right now is using a
million people
because about a million cops I think in
in America as as a tool as a tool you
know they're definitely using it and and
people don't ever stop and think that's
just a dude that needed a job that got
into this career that's making a living
that goes home and has a family is just
trying to get back alive and just
dealing with crazy [ __ ] all [ __ ] day
and he's been crazy dealing with crazy
[ __ ] for like 15 years
why are we allowing this why are we
allowing this to happen you know but
nobody wants to be the person that
stands and raises their hand because
that's that's the next guy so yeah I I'm
not a media fan I imagine most of
America is not a media fan at this point
you know yeah things that do look it's
one of the reasons why we've been able
to start like tertiary immediate things
like this yes you know because
mainstream it was just too
too biased it's so it's bad it's if they
give too the news got away from telling
you what happened and now they give you
their opinion on what happened and it's
based on who that guy is and who's
paying that guy or whatever so and it's
based a lot of times by people that have
grown up in a hypothetical comfortable
type of environment where they've never
really knee you know like they've never
needed a cop really they've never you
know except to maybe serve like a
divorce paper they've never knee like
they've never really been an environment
where it's like okay this is what life
is kind of really like for other people
you know
um people got no idea what's going on
people have no idea what's going on in
the world again most cops are cynical
and calloused and there's a [ __ ]
reason for it man because you spend 20
30 years of going and dealing with the
world [ __ ] every single day you really
start getting convinced
world's [ __ ] up man this is a bad
place you know I I had a young
through my process I had a baby and I I
still to this day go
how could how could I how selfish was it
for me to have a kid how selfish is that
I know what a [ __ ] world this is I know
what he's gonna face I know what could
possibly happen I know what walks the
Earth
it was so selfish I wanted a kid so bad
I did it for me and I never even took
into consideration
what I've done I've he's gonna have to
who knows what's gonna happen to him
well I'll tell you one thing that could
happen to him if you're a good dad he's
going to look up one day at his dad and
he's gonna love his dad so much and he
doesn't get to do that if you don't have
him
so that's pretty cool yes yes
yeah yeah and I'm not judging what
you're saying I'm just kind of sharing
another I'm trying to share something
that makes you think positively about it
too I'm sure it's amazing being a dad
but yeah I could imagine that you're
like what what am I bringing somebody
really into because this world to me is
tough this world is ugly this world you
don't like I said you don't know what's
behind this door cops every day get
invited into people's homes Uninvited
yeah you you have never been in the home
besides a party where people didn't want
you there we would go every day into
people's homes that didn't want us there
and they had no choice so every day
we're walking into environments that
normal people don't go into and is it
weird right when you walk in like where
do you stand in the room that's what I
always feel like sometimes I'm looking
at costume like it always seemed like I
don't know where like what I stand here
would I stand here it's it's there's so
much training even in that aspect as far
as tactical advantage and how you stand
gun leg back you know always being they
teach you to watch I would went to so
many Behavior Analysis Cloud courses
where they would teach you based on the
way people sit during interviews if
they're telling the truth or the way
someone's acting when they're sitting of
what could possibly occur next and
everything's tactical cops do everything
for a reason like they 90 of the time
they'll want to bring people out of
their home because that's their
environment we don't know what's in that
environment we don't know what's behind
that door yeah we don't know what's
under that couch cushion so they try to
bring them into the most
um
safe environment they possibly can which
is usually to bring them out of the
house everything a cop does on a call is
all planned it's it's all from training
and there's all a process to it wow yeah
there's a lot there's a lot that people
don't even you know there's a lot to it
man
it's really given me
it just gives me a little bit more of an
understanding kind of of uh this should
almost be a class I feel like in school
when kids are growing up
you know yes to have like a real
like I don't give a [ __ ] if I could
spell but if I have an understanding of
what the people enforcing my community
what their lives are like and what my
responsibility then as a member of the
community could be
um that would be really really valuable
I feel like absolutely I mean even cops
still need it I
before covid after I retired I went in
my one of my close friends in the police
department I became a patrol sergeant
and it was a female most squared away
female cop you've ever seen just looked
at her and she screamed cop great cop
good person totally solid as time went
on she started to deteriorate mentally
and
because my generation never been taught
about it we would you know you just need
to sack yeah suck the [ __ ] up you know
toughen up Tom that's it you need a cup
of sock to [ __ ] up let's get back to
business yeah so we [ __ ] hardened
that vulva buddy that's it you know and
we would not we just didn't know whether
it was well long story short she ended
up not showing up for work and she ended
up killing herself now she ended up
hanging herself and and I actually went
to the house and found her
um and with hindsight looking back at it
there was so many warning signs there
were so many things that she did when
she was begging for help she actually
came into the police department at one
point and was hysterical and acting
crazy and I had a pretty good
relationship with her so I told my
lieutenant I'll go out and talk to her I
want to talk to her and I remember
walking in going holy [ __ ] she's going
to kill herself she's so bad we're like
even thinking that but it was almost
like this passive weird thing that we
just think I said it I said it out loud
she's gonna kill herself she's that
crazy things are that bad right now is
what I was thinking and doing what cops
did we made a [ __ ] joke at her I
remember laughing I remember laughing
and a week later she was dead you know
and so even with cops they have they
have to learn about themselves I was
going and doing speaking based on my
experience from that and some other
things where I was going all over the
United States and doing speaking
engagements where I was teaching cops
just about mental mental health man you
know knowing what can happen and how it
happens and how how you're not going to
be aware that it's happening and these
are the warning signs and don't [ __ ]
around because
you're going to wake up one day people
don't think it'll it'll be them and it
is
oh yeah and it's fast sometimes it is
well I think we could be at this part in
society too and in timeline of society
where
the receptacles we've been using
to
um
to
to Corral and to
um
take care of like the drains like the
the sieves the things that are
that are
the things that were that are the people
that are taking care of us like
mental health professionals cops it
could be we're at this kind of Tipping
Point as a society where it's like we've
almost
we've overburdened them you know and you
know I don't know that but you start to
wonder like
at what point are
we just not able to
be the ones to
like kind of damn or
help alleviate whatever all this kind of
whatever trauma or whatever it is this
continuing
pieces of pain that are alive in in the
universe does that make any sense to you
yeah it's kind of ethereal kind of a
thing I don't know what ethereal means
but
I understand what you're trying to say I
they got to do a better we got to do
better so what can we do then what can
we do for cops what are what are we
doing so you said that God
but it's important it is important but I
mean we're so we're so far down the
ladder as far as like that question of
what can we do for cops
the the first thing just just to get on
the ladder I would say be fair man be
fair you know think about it it's a
million I'm estimating that but I think
there's like a million cops in America
there's a million people
what we're talking about let's let's say
a thousand of them are bad people a
thousand of them is it our duty is it
our job as police officers or would to
and to identify those people get rid of
them absolutely and I got I'm not here
I'm not
advocating for police I I have no
there's no reason for me to right um I'm
being honest with you
I'm not trying to say oh cops or this or
not but you you need to be fair you need
to be fair with cops you know a thousand
were bad
don't go into it with the thought
process that you have don't participate
in what you're seeing you see people
saying you know [ __ ] the police or all
cops are bad or defund the cop you know
find a way
to assist in in that process of going no
you know that's not right these are we
need to identify individuals and we need
to have and people with the argument
they'll have is go well we can't have we
can't have one bad cop you know I mean
there's too much power you know we can't
have one bad cop I agree but it's also
[ __ ] impossible it's also [ __ ]
important it's totally unrealistic and
especially a pressure to put only people
that already have so much pressure on
them yes and it's not really probably
gonna change anything it's just a bunch
of Battle Cry [ __ ] that doesn't
really in the end is it really changing
anything you know it's making us less
safe
that's a good point it's making us less
safe so we do have that dude I really
I'm telling you man we're less safe we
are we are less it feels less safe out
there yeah we're less safe yes we are
especially here in La we are we are much
less safe wow because we have a double
whammy out here we got now they're now
it's shifting into where they're getting
district attorneys that
are are we're we're we're we're
eliminating crime
we're basically saying that there is
right there's no crime there's no crime
like a crime isn't a real thing if we're
not going to press charges for it yeah
like back back when I was a cop like if
you went into a CVS and shoplifted we
would go through a process of of
identifying did you go in there with the
intent to steal which is an easy process
to do where's your wallet I don't have a
wallet where's your form of payment I
don't have any form of payment I have
nothing on me well why'd you go into CVS
well it's obviously white waiting to see
if you went in there to steal yeah so
now it's not just a petty theft now it's
a burglary because you went in there
with the intent to steal which makes it
a different crime yeah you know so it's
a process of identifying people doing
wrong things and and trying to get it to
stop I wasn't a perfect kid I got
arrested when I was a kid I got arrested
several times when this kid you know I
fortunately I came in contact with
police officers
that
that were from what I remember were just
solid human beings and I had a demeanor
because of the way I was raised where I
was very respectful even though I was
wrong so I had a really good interaction
even though I was being held accountable
I went to juvenile hall man you know I
wasn't really doing anything
I wasn't doing I wasn't just stealing or
I was my parents were really strict I
took their car first time I ever got
arrested I took my parents car you know
15 years old yeah you know want to go
see my girlfriend I came home went to
bed and next morning I woke up cops woke
me up my dad called the cops had me
arrested because his his thought process
was is now now we're getting into [ __ ]
where I'm gonna start holding you
accountable and I used to look at it and
go like oh Dad you're such a dick how
would you do that to me but I look back
at it now and go thank God because I
went through enough stuff where one day
I went that's it I don't want to live
like this matter of fact I want to do
the opposite and all my [ __ ] was
misdemeanors and I was able to get rid
of it and go through the process of
becoming a cop but it it made a big
difference for me when you say like how
do we get rid of that one bad cop
that made a big difference for me where
I was legally able to not make mention
of the things that occurred to me as a
juvenile because I got it expunged my
record and it's clearly stated that you
do not have to make that available okay
okay they do a whole background they
talk to people and the people that were
in my life at that time thankfully
didn't make mention of it either so it
was alleviate so I was able to become a
police officer and it served me well man
because I knew what it was like to be
locked up in an 8x10 room for 23 hours
right you had some semblance of it it's
a big deal to take away someone's
Freedom it's monstrous it's crippling
you know I was
16 years old and I did six months in
juvenile hall for taking my parents car
damn that was back in the day you know
you can't you could kill somebody and
you might not get six months now yeah
you know but my parents said we want the
maximum yada yada but when I got out and
I became a police officer eventually I I
kept that matter of fact [ __ ] someone's
gonna probably watch this podcast and my
buddies are gonna be like dude I never
knew that about you but it's just not
something that I brought up because it
made me feel feel less lesser than the
guys I was working with they had this
this lifestyle that they deserved to be
there and I really didn't deserve to be
there I just got lucky
but it served me really really well I
really had an appreciation of that
process and what it does to a person
coming in contact with a cop being
arrested getting put inside of a jail
cell being there for 23 hours you know
at a time I was a kid from Orange County
I got put in a jail cell the first day
with this kid it was a Asian kid I don't
know oh yeah I've seen him yeah this
Asian kid that was in there and we
started talking about what'd you do and
I said I took my parents car and this
guy went on the story was he was like a
watching gang member and they were on
the run and they were in a hotel and
they had a revolver and they had played
Russian roulette with it with a thing
and some dude ended up blowing his head
off and they were scared because the gun
was stolen they put him in the carpet
and they cut the carp they rolled them
up in the carpet and took them in the
San Bernardino Mountains and lit them on
fire I got away for it with it for like
six months oh but I [ __ ] my pants man
you know I mean when that guy told me
that I was like holy [ __ ] dude I was
scared to death yeah [ __ ] I'm never
working in flooring I know that but dang
no that's crazy that's if you're in a
cell with that dude suddenly you're like
damn that's a kid yeah especially if
you're like this isn't the Avenue I want
to be going like if this is even the
intersection I'm starting to meet up
with the world at I want to do a U-turn
um you were talking about local crime
and stuff like that or this type of
break-ins and fever in uh robbery we had
this thing that just happened yesterday
at the Apple Store did you see this
thing no
and these are these Smash and grab
things that happen all the time yes yeah
this is somewhere here in California I
think near Tahoe but at an Apple Store
and it seems to be
and for some reason this seems to be
like a I don't know if this is like a
black it's like a Black Culture thing it
seems to be a lot of times this is kind
of black guys I know it's generalization
I'm okay to make that and I don't mean
that in a rate like black people I'm
just saying I don't know if this is a
like train robbing is probably like a
white crime you know like different
people have sometimes different crimes
in their cultures I don't know if this
yeah I don't I don't there's no way to
police this is there what do you do here
you hear the people in here like are we
supposed to do something what do we do
you know well I do think we have gotten
to a point in the world where we are
eventually going to have to have someone
with a gun everywhere
I mean I'm talking security of some type
right like if you go to if like you're
talking about like these these these
shootings that they have at schools we
could lit we could almost alleviate that
tomorrow we could almost take care of
that situation tomorrow and if you go to
Israel and you try to walk onto a
elementary school there are two highly
trained highly armed military type
Personnel usually more than that that
are guarding that school wow that you
can't you can't even take pictures they
won't even let you take pictures
that would completely alleviate the
situation that we have if we put I know
they got like school resource officers
but it's one cop and it's big schools
yeah and that's just somebody [ __ ]
with a damn whistle I'm talking about
somebody there who's trained yeah and a
couple highly trained very visible if if
there was a guy right there with with a
gun you know that was in that store but
for some reason Society is still
reluctant to go that direction I
understand that guns are scary I
understand that aspect of it but I
really feel like it's our only solution
you know we could alleviate that
situation how do we stop that from going
on
the only really way to do that is to
hold that's not the first time those
kids committed a crime no nobody walks
into a Apple Store starts ripping
[ __ ] phones off the thing with with
pack store those kids have committed a
lot of crimes and I guarantee you those
kids have been arrested at least some of
them yeah and the problem is the
accountability is so low like my example
you know I had the ultimate
accountability there's no difference
between me and those guys I'm not you
know right you're both humans we're both
humans you know I mean and it I was just
held accountable you know and it changed
the way I think I didn't want that
lifestyle we're not doing that anymore
and people are seeing this on TV and
they're seeing that they're getting away
with it and and it's influencing other
people to do it going like what the [ __ ]
you know why don't we go do it I want a
[ __ ] iPhone 14 [ __ ] you know 40
iPhones in a computer and they don't
have that guidance at home maybe they
don't have that that that you know those
parents that are willing to take the
steps to change the behavior
um do you so who would have to hire the
the the security in that position would
that be apple would need to or would
does it become a governmental issue
because it's almost becoming more like
we've ostracized our police departments
publicly so much that security seems
like it's going to become a lot more of
a privatized type of thing do you it's
gonna have to you know they can't really
I mean they do they have Mall Cops with
their actual real police officers at
malls in some cities they have cops that
are high schools they they do what they
can but you know it would require a lot
more funding which I don't quite
understand why there isn't more funding
but um it would have to be private it's
not like apple can't afford to have some
armed guards at every one of their
stores for sure you know and police
would totally be behind it as long as
there was proper training and
communication and we're gonna have to go
that route it's eventually going to have
to go that route there's just no other
solution yeah I agree with you we had
this what about these they had an uh
thing I was looking at Zach if you can
find this about they were going to do
robots
um this is in San Francisco robot dog
yeah
yeah San Francisco will allow police to
deploy robots that kill
Yeah so basically they're gonna this is
this just came out a lot of people were
talking about it but the important
distinction is that they're not arming
them with guns they're arming them with
explosives and they claim that it would
only be used in the most extreme
situations
um so they won't be armed with guns it
would be explosives
yeah I don't I mean San Francisco police
department in itself is one that I what
you're seeing right there take it with a
grain of salt I'm sure it's completely
irrelevant exactly what's going on I
mean you can see the title San Francisco
allowed police to deploy robots that
will kill that's a pretty absurd
statement for what's probably really
going on here right
um and the Associated Press put this out
there this is crazy yeah that they would
also do this
yeah they're pretty they're about the
most middle of the road I felt like AP
but I mean you're right though San
Francisco PD in itself my knowledge of
it
um is is it's much like their community
you know it's very it's a very um
hopeful hopeful group yeah a very
hopeful group you know I mean they're
okay with a lot of stuff they're they're
really okay with the idea there's
there's so many things that they do
let's let's give make really readily
available needles for heroin addicts you
know right which I understand they are
safe shooting or whatever yeah I
understand the argument of it but
there's just not a lot of thought
process well they wanted to give swords
to homeless people I remember a couple
years ago there was a thing about giving
homeless people swords so they could
help defend themselves and I'm like
what the [ __ ] are we doing dude homeless
I mean there's another great example man
the homeless situation we have [ __ ]
ourselves on that we have totally [ __ ]
ourselves when I first started in police
work there really is no available answer
for homelessness because it's a mix of
people it's people that want to be there
it's people that are drug addicts it's
people that are mentally mentally
uncapable you know we used to have the
process where we would be able to
someone go I got a homeless guy he's
taking [ __ ] in front of my house you
know we'd be able to go there take that
person and alleviate the problem for the
person that's calling us we would take
them somewhere else let me take you to
this part let me take you where can I
take it is there any way I can take it
take it to let me take you 7-Eleven I'll
get you some water I'll buy you a little
something to eat you know and and then
you can go on your way and they go okay
I'll do that
early on in my career and I forget the
agency but a cop kind of did that where
he took a homeless person away from a
situation where someone was calling
drove him to the edge of the city and
said walk that way so the idea was
you're not my City's problem okay and
somehow some attorney got a hold of that
information
um and decided that he was going to take
this to court because that cop took
someone that had not committed a crime
and against his will transported in from
one location to another which is the
definition of kidnapping so they ended
up going after this cop for kidnapping
so then what ends up happening by case
law is it changes the process the way
all police departments handle homeless
people
you know there's no more doing that so
basically they even made it worse then
they start saying oh you took that guy
to jail and you left this his cart full
of [ __ ] here which is full of
yeah memorabilia things from growing up
trophies from when he was in t-ball I
wish it's usually full of [ __ ] man oh
yeah it's just disgusting you know extra
urine yeah socks full of weird [ __ ] that
he chewed on and whatever and they
glitter yeah whatever we saw a dude with
a whole canister a glitter one time
we're like what oh I had I had a
homeless guy that was so bad and when we
booked them in his sock was he had a
athletic sock and with the stripes on it
filled with cash over three thousand
dollars wow and he was sitting in a
gutter eating dirt you know it's just
crazy the people were giving him money
but they start saying that we have to
book all their property in you literally
got to take that shopping cart
individually go through it itemize it
process and put a thing so now cops went
oh hell no right I'm not doing this now
oh hell no I don't have the time right I
don't want the disease you've made it
totally unreasonable so again Society
completely screwed themselves on how we
as a society can help you with a problem
if you had a homeless guy sitting on
your front of your door that that cop's
in a pickle you know he can still do
things and try to convince this guy to
leave but all the real tools that we had
the real methods we used the world got
rid of them well why do we and it is a
lot of times it's lawyers that [ __ ]
ruin all this [ __ ] lawyers ruined
everything the lawyers really have
they've ruined everything civilized
civil law has ruined everything civil
law has destroyed our country it really
has and Americans they love civil law
there's so many people getting rich yeah
no off civil law
man
but the mental the mental the mental
expense and the emotional expense of all
of that type of stuff all those rules
the laws the impossibility of it that
the average human the average American I
think because this is a really a lot of
its American issues uh I think we're
getting to the point where we're at our
Tipping Point a lot of people are on
medication a lot of people are stressed
beyond the gills we can't people are not
um able to have children as easily
anymore everybody's going through all
this fertilization you know stuff I
think there's tons of stressors
um I think we're getting to that point
where
it's a little bit at the Tipping Point
you don't know what a CVS now if you are
safe or not you know like I was there
the other day
in the makeup Lady is now tussling with
some [ __ ] 6'4 man in there yeah and
she's just trying to
you know make sure that this guy doesn't
mash up her station you know like is the
guy's running around taking stuff right
yeah and so then like you have people
who they have to be enforcers now and
she's just the makeup person and the
photo guy you know it's like they
shouldn't have to be enforcers so it's
like
um and then the truth is they probably
should just let Insurance handle it or
whatever you know so it's like
I don't know we've just gotten ourselves
into this place it feels like a lot of
times where
the people who are supposed to be
helping us our therapists our police or
the people that are kind of like add
this buffer to society to make us stay
well
um are kind of stressed to the gills it
feels like sometimes yeah I don't know
who's gonna police the world coming up
especially now with everything that's
going on who's going into law
enforcement right now yeah what's that
been like has there been lower amounts
of people going in have you heard or
anything uh no I mean I I there it's
but it seems scary yeah they've
tightened the standards they've made it
harder because the world's going like oh
you know the police are doing everything
they can to go we need the we need the
best candidates we don't want these
problems again in the future
the testing process of becoming a police
officer is it's extraordinary I mean
it's really extraordinary the tests I
had to go through you know psychologists
uh written tests physical tests
um I mean there's just so many
interviews backgrounds they went in my
background they went and talked to
everybody no oh dude everybody they talk
to my ex-girlfriends and everybody
that's a good one and they also seal it
and they so you never get to know what
they said which is really well you
should get it when you're done dude on
the way out I knew where it was and I
thought many times I'm gonna go in there
and [ __ ] pilf this [ __ ] but I didn't
want to [ __ ] with my pension who knows
what they could do you know what I mean
so but the who's going to police who's
going to do it who's going to take this
job I remember as a kid
you know again I think today I wouldn't
be able to be a police officer I today
they require like I had I got my degree
when I was a cop so I could become a
detective okay so I went to college in
in while I was working now they really
won't even talk to you in the hiring
process unless you have a degree they're
they're they're they're they're up
really standards yeah and are they
paying more yeah well it's it's
Progressive that's a good year it's like
three percent I remember being a kid I
was 21 years old I was making like sixty
thousand dollars a year you know for a
21 year old dude I was I was big pimping
dude you know I was huge I was huge and
I was shooting bullets in the Airing
damn catching them out dude I always
felt like I was being fairly compensated
I guess because once I got into it I it
was so exciting I hated the weekend I
loved to work I couldn't wait to get to
work next day because what the [ __ ]
gonna go on today that's how it was
every day for a long time when I was
young and I always felt like the money
was fair you know
um just give you an idea California is
the highest paid please police officers
in the world wow they're also the most
trained and I'm sure there's somebody
that's going to disagree with that from
somewhere else but it just it is okay
that's why a lot of the stuff you see
you'll see like in uh no bang on
Kentucky but some police officer in a
place like Kentucky you know doing
something stupid you're going like
that's crazy the show Cops yeah I
actually had cops ride with me you did I
did have cops right with me you'd be
interested in how that goes how that
process is to get one we're going to
talk about that in a minute remember
that Zach so we don't forget that the uh
you watch I watch Cops a lot of times
just go like oh my God I can't believe
what this guy's doing you know they're
tacticals and their tactics and all that
kind of stuff oh yeah but I just don't
know I don't know what it's going to be
like because I do feel like you need to
pull as many people from different
aspects of society
just to have that rounded structure of
of you know I had a lot of compassion
for the the arrest process for people
going into it this guy doesn't
understand that he's a good dude he's
doing the right thing but he has no idea
the impact of taking someone putting
them a handcuffing him into a cage
putting him in a cage the guy had to go
to work tomorrow we impounded his car
he's only got 300 bucks in the it's just
monstrous and I had a real feel for that
right and in reality if they had known
everything about me
they would have probably said nah we're
going to pass on you and I was
successful you know I wasn't the best or
anything like that but I was very
successful and I was good at the
compassion aspect I think if you went
back and talked to everybody they would
go like yeah your heart was too big for
this job to start with and I kind of
disagree with that I just understood I
understood what what we're doing here
this is a big deal yeah you know you you
you try to explain to somebody
anytime somebody dies in a car accident
in a murder
um when I was a homicide detective for a
period you you have to somebody has to
go tell that family
that your loved one's not dead because
they don't know at that point you know
um do you try to act like when you walk
up do you try to act like you don't like
because their look like that would be
the part for me if a cop comes and
knocks on my door do you want to look
like you have that information or is the
goal at first to not look like you have
that information
man you we are now in a conversation
this that was one of the probably the
the hardest aspect is notifying people
that their loved one's dead and when you
eat through one of them okay uh I I had
I'm gonna give you a a traffic accident
I had a traffic accident where a 16 year
old female was killed
um and I went they'd start the
investigation and usually they'll take
someone that's never done it before or
whatever to go do the notification at
that time I was on patrol and they said
Hey listen you gotta go make a
notification by the end it was like
three four o'clock in the morning and if
you're a parent and your kid's out and
the cop knocks on the door at four
o'clock in the morning
the blood leaves your face it just does
you know that's just the way it is you
know I mean and I I remember I did many
of these and as they went on they got
way more difficult but I remember
knocking on the door
and being so nervous that it felt like
my esophagus had seized like I literally
couldn't talk I'm thinking they're gonna
come to the door I'm not going to be
able to talk right now
and I remember it was it was a mother
she came to the door and she just woke
up and as soon as she saw me
I didn't have to say anything you know
something was wrong she knew that
something was very wrong
and the process of informing a love
apparent especially that their child is
dead when you first start doing it
you're blunt because that's what you're
there to do you know and I came I said
you know are you the parent of yagata
and by then they're already crying and
you so I'm sorry to inform you but your
daughter was killed in a traffic
accident
and this woman in particular because it
again this these are the trials of
police officers it it right now I feel
like I want to cry yeah same yeah I mean
it just does that to you and it's it's
um
but I have a I have a thousand of these
you know what I'm saying so I remember
I remember her getting to the point and
her falling on the ground and
as many movies as I've seen of trying to
depict police situations
there's nobody and there's nothing that
could do that accurately to really
depict of what that looks like it's a
pain that to this day you know I'm
probably 20 years now out from that
situation close to
it still makes me want to cry just
bringing it up it brings it you know I
get the pain and
as you do those and as you go through
them I had a dad that a girl had hung
herself and he was so upset that he
grabbed me by the shirt and he started
no no and like kind of pushed me back
and he had a suburban and he pushed me
into the Suburban my elbow went through
the back window of his thing that's how
hard he pushed me
and I knew what was happening there he
wasn't mad at me this guy was just so
grieving but as those go on as those
situations occur and as you do more and
more of those and as you introduce new
officers
and take them to do it
it becomes so much more difficult I
remember sitting out front of homes
towards the end of my career
sitting in the car and and I was a
sergeant of time and I wouldn't send
young guys because I just couldn't
fathom me doing that to them because I
knew what it had done it's done to me
you know what I mean so I remember
looking
at the this particular one it was the
morning it was like six o'clock in the
morning because the sun was coming up
and I remember seeing them walking in
front of the window of their home in the
kitchen and me realizing okay I got 45
minutes till my shifts up I'm gonna sit
here for 45 more minutes because these
are the last 45 minutes of these
people's lives
you know what I mean and because I was
at that point in my career it was gone
off now I was crying
just the thought of doing this I had my
own child now it just it became so much
larger now of doing them for so many
times that I sat there forever
putting it off as long as I can and then
walking up to it it it's Indescribable
it really truly is Indescribable
knocking on a door and telling someone
their most precious whatever husband
wife dad son Grandma anything is gone
and and the scenario that you do that is
so it's so vast you know there's so many
old people that live alone and the
family lives far away and and no one's
really accounting for them and it's
August and they [ __ ] die on Thursday
and by Tuesday the neighbors going
something stinks next door and there's
[ __ ] flies all over the window and
they send you out at two three o'clock
in the morning and you got a [ __ ]
flashlight and you're walking up to the
house you look at the window going [ __ ]
yeah something's dead in here man you
can smell it yeah which is a smell you
never forget you net you know exactly
the smell of death really oh exactly I
can if if there's something dead and
that smell is permeating in the air I
smell it I tell you if something's dead
Within These parameters do you know it's
human usually or not can you tell human
or not no I don't I don't know right I
don't know that but I know human okay
but and you start going through that
this is just a whole different story you
start going through that house man you
know you got to kick the door in you
know because no one answers the door and
it's dark and you're so [ __ ] scared
and wigged out
that you don't even take the time to hit
light switches to turn the light on
you're going in with a flashlight which
makes it a million [ __ ] times worse
you know it's like be smart hit the
light switch at least it's there but
you're going around corners going okay
this is the [ __ ] door you know and
I've kicked open so many doors and seen
the most horrific [ __ ] dude you can ever
imagine in your entire life oh you know
how many dudes die taking a [ __ ] A lot
of them huh a lot very prevalent for old
people there's actually a medical term
for it no really what is it I I couldn't
tell you just bring it up Zach we can
get that information yeah the pushing of
a bowel movement it stops their heart
and I can't tell you how many times I've
had the dudes on the ground and have to
force open the door because their body's
in the way to the toilet and they're
just rigamorted yeah and do are they
usually like this or are they more like
this well Rigamortis has a process or do
they do like this no they fall off the
toilet no yeah they fall off the toilet
oh dang yeah they thought so they're
blocking the door that's what I'm saying
you got to push the door so you're
pushing the door and it's just something
gruesome about pushing a body you know
and trying to get around I'm looking at
and usually they're they're in like in
August if you don't find someone for a
week in August and they never turn the
air conditioning on that body's in a
state of [ __ ] disaster I mean is it
bloated
that whole process that's a process wow
the death process Rigamortis sets in it
comes out then you start bloating you
get you know I've had them where they're
bloated so big that there's big water
blisters on their back and like the
corner a little corn or little Asian
girl dressed to the nines with a little
suit on damn boy yeah yeah a really
pretty little girl and a dad is to meet
her you know yeah you don't want to deal
with the coroner dude those are some
those are some different people you've
got to be are they really pretty
sketched out on some damn Wednesday
Adams is huh yeah well dude I had a
coroner at L.A County coroner's office
that uh we were in there on a autopsy
which is a whole different story
autopsies are disgusting they're brutal
they use saws and they use hedge
clippers to cut the the rib cages away
oh because they canoe them they'll they
take away your rib cages and they take
all your guts out they cut your they cut
your head they peel your hair forward so
your hair is touching your face they cut
your Dome off and take out the brain and
all kinds of wicked stuff but afterwards
as a homicide investigator we would go
to those because we'd want to see the
trajectory of the bullets and get a
determination of what they determine how
far and all the different evidence you
can get from an autopsy I had this dude
that did an autopsy gloves covering
blood and he went in to talk to me and
he went into this little lunchroom and
he got his lunch out and he took off his
gloves this [ __ ] pulled out a sandwich
like a meat sandwich that meat in it and
as he's talking to me as he's talking to
me he's eating a meat sandwich man and I
remember being digging my fingers into
my leg just like oh just to not think
about it because it was so it was making
me so nauseous you know yeah I don't
think I could have a damn Turkey Tom or
somebody just laying there you know
Corners are a different breed man you
got to be a different breed to be
chopping up people all day long yeah
even as to be taken yeah like you're
taking vitamins or yeah if you're going
to be on an exercise bike or something
in the same room as like a body just
creep so weird yeah well anyway back to
the real quick on the Asian the Asian
girl she had to flip she had to flip
this body over that was bloated so she
put a rope around the opposite side the
lady's wrist and this lady was deep in
the decomposing and she threw the Rope
over the lady and she went on their side
and she was going to pull this rope so
the arm would flip her over and she'd be
able to see the front of her so she's
pulling this rope over and because the
body was so decomposed it ripped off the
skin of the entire arm and and the body
fluids of this lady went straight up on
her and on her face and in her mouth it
was all over her and this girl literally
she you know she was shocked for a
second and she's oh my God she said some
things and she went over and got some
wet wipes and everything and she wiped
off her face and she just went back the
[ __ ] business man he just ate a damn
butterscotch out of her purse dude
jamming temperature things or the liver
and [ __ ] crazy man crazy crazy that's
the dark arts dude that is when you were
a real concierge of the devil I feel
like if you're there doing coronation
yeah cornerizing that's definitely a
relationship killer man I would suggest
anybody if you find out you're dating
someone at the coroner
that's going to be a strange life yeah
man that's really gonna be because
they're going to want to watch you sleep
you know yeah
uh forever maybe yeah pull up that
information you had there Zachary if you
don't mind I had a defecation syncope is
the name for dying while you're shooting
what is it again and are you dying you
sound sick Zach I'm okay uh it's
defecation syncope yeah there you go
okay pretty prevalent what does it say
about it can you tell it just give us a
little more Intel
defecation syncope describes the Vaso
vaginal response that occurs while
defecating that results in a loss of
consciousness wow yeah for all people
the loss of consciousness results from
bearing down to increase the pressure in
the rectum damn boy
so I guess yeah you can have to I mean
this guy just [ __ ] himself to death
really
God yeah it happens pretty often with
older people something with their heart
stops their heart and they die and
they're by themselves and uh yeah pretty
brutal pretty brutal life is pretty
brutal life is I always felt like it
would be a good thing for the world to
have
some kind of a venue where like I got a
million stories you know I got a million
things I've experienced we're
one guy one cop one story you know and
just to give the world the idea of
what's going on
because nobody knows what's going on you
think you're so you just the perception
of how many police there are any given
night and I'm gonna give you the example
the city of Whittier which is a pretty
big city
there was
four or five cops that's it
that's it you know I mean that's all
that there was now granted there's a lot
of police around and right and they'll
come but that's you're not really safe
with just four or five cops you know
what I mean like I to this day I'm
telling you I could Rob any Bank yeah I
know exactly how to do it really could
get away oh absolutely I'm not gonna say
it I don't want to yeah but I could
absolutely write it down for me yeah
just because there's such a lack of of
officers there's such a lack of Staffing
you know there's such a we're just
unsafe and I think if if someone could
put something together where they just a
cop just came and say hey this is this
is a story and people start hearing that
every day and just going like dude the
world
stuff that's going on in the world right
now you know the stuff that goes on
every day and has always gone on is
always is going to go on I think people
would be a little more understanding of
of the difficulty of the job you know
the difficulty of
policing the world you know maybe a
little more less judgmental you know a
little less harsh
oh well I think this conversation alone
and I've always been kind of I mean
pretty much pro-police I mean if it's a
bad policeman I'm a uh be against that
person if there's a bad anything I'd
kind of be against that person or at
least want to investigate what's going
on with them but you know we grew up in
a real poor environment and so the cops
would always hang out around the poor
people because we were outside a lot and
so when I was growing up we'd be outside
so the cops I think sometimes would be
on their [ __ ] you know and they they'd
stop and chat you know I feel like you
kind of knew the cops better when you
were poor because
you were outside there'd be more calls
to your neighborhood because somebody
was always doing something there was
always some domestic violence or
somebody was you know you know butting
some drugs or something small you know
just some small ball locally so the cops
would be around so you get to kind of
know them you know
um
and they're it was kind of fun in a way
you know and then one of them would
start dating somebody in the
neighborhood you know
like not dicey but just like you know I
remember chicks thought it was kind of
hot to date a cop you know when I was
growing up it was like yeah I get to
date a cop would you say that now it
seems crazy I can't imagine there's any
girls going oh I want to date a cop yeah
I mean really who would want to date a
cop now
yeah I mean I don't know I think there's
so there's still a lot of like you know
America first type people I think who
believe that cops are good people you
know and so those people would probably
be fine with it I think maybe more
scared for the cops probably there might
be more fear in that sense
yeah the lifestyle again it goes down to
they just don't know you know it's a
tough life my you know
my wife's married a cop you know tough
life God tough life you know but I I'm
out now and things are good and but it's
it's a tough life it's it's a different
life the world doesn't know what's going
on out there you have no idea what's
going on out there I do yeah it's a hard
reality to live with you never feel safe
well and it's just not fair that there's
not an accurate kind of representation
of what goes on out there's there's not
that that person you call they're exp
you guys are expected to handle so much
like some people are mentally unwell
somebody somebody's got a gun somebody's
doing sex trafficking somebody's trying
to hide a kid in their attic you know
it's like you don't [ __ ] know nope
you never know what you're walking into
either many situations where you think
it's one thing and it's something
totally different you know what I mean
did you get a lot of was there a lot of
that because you know a few years ago
sex trafficking was like the big buzz
you know it was like you'd see things on
Commercial like there's a million women
being sex trafficked in America and I'm
like that's [ __ ] insane but uh I I
could believe that there's some of it
you know but I don't think there's a
million way you know like you'd see some
every few years is like a big thing yeah
a big push you know yeah I don't to be
honest I don't know I don't know I never
really dealt with a lot of that I never
I don't unders I don't have a lot of
knowledge on that so it'd be pretty
responsible for me to make a comment
about that but in my police career
I dealt with prostitutes you know
without there was a lot of stuff with
prostitution and were they just trying
to survive most of where most of them
just women trying to survive or most of
them women that you found that had been
in a b where that were being abused by a
man and used to sex money and sex you
know what I didn't I I couldn't answer
that because
I never really very rarely would have an
intimate conversation with someone I was
dealing with right I deal with enough I
don't need I don't want to know the
story the story is irrelevant you know
they start getting the stories it can
kind of change the way you handle stuff
and the reality of it is that you were
soliciting I'm just dealing with
soliciting
you know if they go into a story of oh
my God my dad raped me and this and that
you as a human being I think you would
tend to go like oh my God this poor
thing and
I just got to deal with the situation
because right if she gives me a story
and I let her off because her story sad
well how how fair is it the next
prostitute that I arrest them just
because I don't listen to their story
it's another difficulty of it you know
right that plays a lot with tickets you
know tickets man or tickets are a big
deal dude everyone gets pulled over and
and they want they want to be get get
out of the ticket you know come on man
help me out do me but the reality of it
is if you were driving 75 miles per hour
and I pulled you over um
and you're I notice who you are you're a
cool guy or we have a conversation or
you're very upfront go totally my fault
totally so sorry and I go okay man just
slow down God the next guy I pull over
that's doing the same exact thing I
don't give him the opportunity to talk
because maybe I'm in a rush or I don't
know who he is and I give him a ticket
well now I've done I've done something
wrong right you know what I mean I've
done something wrong so there's a real
dilemma with that so when you start
giving people breaks when they're the
next person you're doing wrong so that's
that's an aspect people never really
think of so if you're really doing
policing right there is no gray right
but we all want them to deal with the
gray and I dealt with the gray
constantly you know and is it a real
thing that you have to like people like
all right we we we the city needs to
make money we need 10 because
everybody's guilty when they get pulled
99 of the time yes so is that a real
thing it's like hey we got to make sure
if you're if you're letting people off
we can't let them off any more in the
next month as far as like quotas and
stuff like that no they're too smart for
that this is how they do it there there
is no quotas but what they'll do is is
they'll say you've got to be within five
tickets of the team average the team
being the watch that's going out okay so
day watch is usually guys that have been
on for a long time that just want to
work nine to five Monday through Friday
those guys don't do [ __ ] yeah I mean
they're doing the absolute minimum
because they're burnout they're tired
they're old
their tickets are going to be really
super low so what the department does is
they'll take a guy fresh out of the
academy you can't wait to write some
tickets yeah and they'll throw them on
day watch so now that guy's writing 40
tickets [ __ ] penmanship Henry out
there yeah just doing it you know for
everything yeah so they'll put that guy
on the watch and he'll write 40 tickets
in a month now the expectation is for
everyone else has got to be at about 30
to 33 or you're gonna get on your eval
so is there a quota no there is no quota
we just got to be within the team
average which is the average that we
should be at right again civil liability
it's a way to beat around it you know
what I mean that's what they'll do
that's how they'll they'll get the
tickets they need
uh let's get you another water I gotta
pee yeah yeah I got P2 we can uh we can
jump back on for a few minutes yeah my
dad was no my dad was a great dude man
he just was no there was no [ __ ]
with my dad really no [ __ ] he's
third poor grew up in Ardmore Oklahoma
oh wow he backyard was a cemetery dad
was drunk died young used to beat him
you know the whole deal he
he was white trash my dad was that's
self-proclaimed white trash you know had
nothing
shoes with holes all the stories and
[ __ ] um but he became a really
successful executive he was the vice
president of Hebrew National we're not
Jewish but with Hebrew National wieners
yeah Frank's wow and this his brother
became a doctor you know wow that's huge
they came from nothing oh it's huge when
you come from not the man for somebody
to be a [ __ ] doctor for I remember in
our neighborhood somebody was a lunch
lady
and we were like damn Miss Annie
she made it well you say that but his
brother who became a doctor
guys he's like a [ __ ] serial killer
really yeah he got raided by the SWAT
and he was he was one of the guys that
was writing prescriptions oh he was yeah
yeah yeah well that thing that whole
thing was crazy do you see that uh dope
sick that yeah very good how insane is
that
say a second Dope Sick it was like that
document it was like a television show I
think it was on Hulu I watched it I was
trying to think what the content was it
was like Michael uh who was in it Zach
um Michael Michael Keaton Michael Keaton
and he was a doctor and he got on he
started prescribing these pills because
it they made him sound safe and
everybody in his town got hooked yes
yeah and then he got hooked that was
huge I'll tell you something I I I
worked I was a police officer I was in
narcs during the heart of that opioid
epidemic opioid epidemic and yeah and it
was some Jewish Family I think that ran
Sackler family where were they
that that actually owned the business
that owned the business and they kept
compromising oh yeah Sackler family they
kept compromising officials and um
getting them to work and bribing people
it's unbelievable how they kept it in
business yeah what was that like to
opioid epidemic on the street level
um well we at the time it was going on
they weren't calling in an opioid opioid
endemic right they weren't they weren't
there was no identifying it but we
started noticing that
we would catch guys coming out of
dentist office and they would they would
have different kinds of containers one
of the ones that was real prevalent for
some reason was these little square like
lunch coolers and they'd have them
filled with prescription bottles and we
called them Fishers and what they would
do is they would go to these low-end
doctors and dentists and they would just
fill prescript find these doctors that
go oh my back hurts they go okay let me
write you a prescription and move this
out a little bit more for me or just
like this way yeah okay they would um
they would fill they'd find all these
doctors that would fill prescriptions
and they would go to like 10 doctors a
day and we'd catch them and they'd have
like a thousand pills you know we start
going this is really becoming prevalent
we're finding this more and more
and I think we actually had a guy OD out
front of a dentist office and somehow we
found in his prescriptions that the
prescription was from that dentist and
that's how we kind of got turned on and
it started going in motion is finding
out what's going on here man is that
these doctors somehow are making
tremendous amounts of money billing
insurance by these guys coming in and
saying my knee hurts and them just do
give him a prescription right bill the
insurance get a bunch of money and
knowing this guy's going to be back in
about three days I'm just going to do it
again you know what I mean and these
guys would go to like five six seven
doctors
yeah they had that documentary about a
kid in New Orleans that got murdered uh
buying some pills and it led to the dad
like searching out this entire like uh
like kind of pill farming thing that was
going on there I can't remember the name
of that
um it was pretty fascinating though the
pharmacist the pharmacist that was it I
actually tried to reach out to that Dad
and even have him come on as a guest I
mean it was the story is just so tragic
but then he busts he helps bust this
doctor
um who was I mean given out insane
amounts of pills every day they would
show like they had like footage outside
of her Pharmacy or whatever and they'd
have like 50 60 people out there just
waiting at like yeah at like up till
like 1am and they'd have a security
guard uh like having them go in one at a
time and she was just sitting in there
writing scripts when they finally found
her she was geeked out to the gills yeah
just insane um was there ever instances
where cops would start using the Dr like
in to help relieve some of their own
like PTSD and stuff that was going on
that they ever does that become an issue
ever
um I'm trying to think firsthand if I I
know of any I don't really I mean
drinking there was always guys that
always drank but that's always been
socially acceptable yeah I'm just
thinking if it yeah because those those
the opioids it's such an easy thing to
just take and use you know it's a good
example that you were saying like and I
this is when I'm kind of reluctant
because I don't want to cause any
problems for people in police work right
now but
pulling from General Society police
departments are staffed by people from
the community they go through a hiring
process and they get oh yeah we get
everything and this is a good example of
people judging the cops based on the
actions of one person or a dozen or so
we actually at my Police Department had
two different cops one I worked with
forever one I knew right off the bat
that were child molesters damn that we
found out they were talking as a matter
of fact the one officer that um that we
caught the first one he molested the son
of one of our other officers they were
best friends so again you're talking
about a situation where the world goes
we can't even have one bad cop well [ __ ]
we're with you on you know not right
we're with you but we're also this piece
of a piece of society we're dealing with
it too yeah you know we're dealing with
it too as soon as we find out that's
there I mean we we obviously this guy
was gone in prison and we
we handled that situation but um
we're no different than anybody else you
know cops are no different the people
that are cops are no different than
anybody else as far yeah it's kind of
funny if you took a group of guys and
you just showed me a group of guys I
don't know if I'd know if they were cops
or not unless you put the uniforms on
them you know certain ones right some
guys yeah some guys got the high and
tight and a big mustache and you know
they're always wearing a fanny pack yeah
but you know what so yeah right as soon
as you see that guy though even
even cops look at that guy and go like
dude you're mowing your [ __ ] lawn put
your gun away you know right cop it down
a little yeah totally totally yeah
that's great yeah and those are the guys
that end up being 23 years old and going
to the nightclub with a gun on them
right you know what I mean I'm a cop
yeah yeah I mean I mean how stupid can
you be you know how stupid can you be
going into a drinking situation carrying
a gun because if someone punches you in
the face what are you gonna do yeah
punch him with a bullet yeah yeah that's
where you see stuff like that gun them
yeah for sure
um there was a couple of what do you
think about this so when you get in when
you got into detectiving did you
detective anything like this uh Idaho
murder do you follow that kind of stuff
do you follow crimes sometimes like
especially high profile no I don't feel
anything um I I don't even want to know
about it but uh high profile most of my
murders were domestic and Gang Related
okay where I was at I didn't have
anything particularly high profile
um I had a lot of
domestic situations which
real quick on one
um
this is a good example for you too for
hotels I'll give you a little
information on hotels
you never know what goes on in hotels
man any hotel room you're in I'm going
to give you a little touch of some stuff
that goes on in those hotels before you
you checked in we had a situation on a
murder where a guy got arrested for
domestic violence okay I'm taking into
custody for whatever reason the judge
sentenced them to 90 days but decided
he's going to give him 24 hours to get
his Affairs in order before he reports
to go into custody which is nuts which
is totally totally nuts so he releases
this guy this guy immediately goes and
kidnaps the girl that he beat takes her
to a hotel in our city
in the hotel he executes her shoots her
in the back of the head she falls on the
bed and then blows his head off
he actually puts it up to his thing so
he's on the ceiling
um his the brain's everything on the
ceiling so when we get a cleaning lady
tried to get in because he'd put a table
against the door and sees it and calls
us so we get there we push open the door
and enough time had passed where the
woman had fallen onto the bed it was one
of those cheap polyester type yeah bed
spreads and it it's almost holds water
so when she bled out it it it
accumulated in that thing so her face
was in the blood
where you couldn't see any of her face
she was face down and it was already
coagulating on top so it was like a
giant scab on top you know what I'm
saying he was all over the ceiling and
falling back we do the investigation we
get everything done totally gruesome
totally gross
it was like late late three four o'clock
in the morning that we leave and the
next day I didn't come in I came in the
next day and I needed to get some
information from the hotel so I went
back to the hotel and I go into the
office and so I'm going in the office
this is less than 24 hours well a little
bit over 24 hours and I look up there's
a [ __ ] family walking out of that
hotel room
they're going out to go about do
whatever they're going to do and I walk
in the office said dude you rented that
hotel room out how did you get it clean
and this guy went on to explain to me
how they have people on standby and he
got it clean and they painted this and
painted that
no mention to that family 24 hours ago
there was a double murder in that hotel
room crazy that's a small story on hotel
rooms dang man that's God what yeah
oh we'll leave the light on for you huh
yeah no [ __ ] now this kind of Hotel it
was we'll leave the light on my God yeah
crazy again a perfect example of the
world just doesn't know what walks the
Earth
you know well it's just another example
also of Are We processing the travesties
that happen are we or are we just you
know are we still able how much travesty
and you know stuff has built up that we
just can't even process it as a society
you know even things like that it's like
turning around like is there some is
there a little bit of a Vibe where maybe
the [ __ ] kid you know one of the kids
sleeping in there develops a cancer 40
years from now because he [ __ ] slept
in the aura of a you know two deceased
people nine hours after that yeah for
real you know I I look and it's some of
that's kind of like this you know it's
more this
you know imaginative sort of thinking
but I don't know how much of it it is
you know
um well I I also came up in the meth lab
time California was full of meth labs
when I first started your motor running
meth labs were scary man really you
usually found a meth lab a lot of the
times you would discover a meth lab
because it'd blow up because those are
volatile they blew up all the time so
you can't shoot in there no no [ __ ] he
found a meth lab you had to back out
quick because I mean meth is just made
out of red lie and Coleman lantern fluid
lighter fluid just all kinds of [ __ ]
that yeah you have no business ingesting
you know what I mean it's all volatile
there's gases and they always would blow
up unless you want to [ __ ] for a long
time I think it's okay to have a little
yeah you know I mean don't have you ever
called some people do sex on meth for a
long time right yeah with a dildo with a
code anger oh my God yeah sorry I had to
take you back there
yeah yeah I mean the D Tweakers Tweakers
were Tweakers are the live on yeah
Tweakers the lifeblood a place where the
difference the only Tweakers are so
different than any other drug heroin
addicts
marijuana real touch real quick on
marijuana police work in marijuana I
identified really quick I'm not a
marijuana Advocate but I identified
really quick that this is ridiculous
that this is against the law every
single person I ever came in contact
that was stoned never gave me a problem
at all in fact they were some of the
best contacts I ever had wow Best
Contacts I identified really early that
this is something that's just it needs
to go away every dude that was drunk was
a nightmare and that was legal and this
is not I can go on forever and tell you
that is it is ridiculous and why uh why
do we have those laws against marijuana
because I old white people you know back
in the day yeah just hysteria they
didn't know what it was they didn't
understand I don't know I don't know why
but Devil's lettuce or whatever all that
[ __ ] yeah but we're getting better
California's good the rest of the
world's getting better I really believe
they should be legal everywhere for sure
100 but drugs as far as druggos heroin
addicts they do heroin they stay home
they nod out right pills stay home you
know marijuana the fun nitrous oxide
whatever drug you talk about it's not an
issue methamphetamine man [ __ ] does
methamphetamine dude he cannot stay home
he cannot stay home he's got to get to
he's got to get to work wow and it's
always at night you know that's when we
get to work we would find Tweakers they
had all these different processes of how
they get their money copper was a real
big one they love copper they would wipe
out whole
housing tracks you know of their copper
but you'd get the occasional one which I
had one actually I think I had two where
they would go into industrial complexes
and they would go into these massive
warehouses that had those giant metal
cabinets that had the the what like tin
wires that were coming down it that were
like
20 inch in diameter you know I mean just
massive fiber optic wires and all that
no they was just like electricity there
was like a box where the main
electricity would come in and it would
all Branch off that but inside that
there'd be massive wiring and these
lockers would go in there and they'd try
to cut that wiring out and be live so it
would cook them dude I mean it would
just they would instantly just get
electrocuted and either a fire or
there'd be different ways that it would
that we would become aware of it that we
get there but by the time you got there
these guys would be onion rings I mean
onion rings because if it's been flowing
through them flowing through them and
what do they start to look like kind of
like a jet like a jerky do they start to
look like uh burnt completely totally
burnt wow completely does it almost they
almost look fake yes a lot of that [ __ ]
looks fake a lot of the stuff that's
really brutal I had an industrial
accident where a guy got sucked into a
turbine it was a big giant piece of
Machinery that had this like shaft that
was a spinning shaft that came out of
the engine and it was about I don't know
about four feet off three feet off the
ground round I'd say and it ran to
another engine of some type and they had
that covered with metal like Gates so
without things metal no one could touch
it and it was in the front well these
guys in the warehouse were playing
football
and the dude threw the football and he
missed it and it went into where those
things were so this dumbass decided to
step over the gate where those things
were spinning a billion miles an hour to
get the football and the sweater he had
tied around his waist got sucked into it
and it taffied them it sucked them into
the piston and and wrapped him around it
and by the time he was completely
wrapped up into it his head had been
hitting the concrete so many times that
was going around that it emptied his
insides
perfectly so it was on the ceiling on
the back wall and then shot across the
thing so when we got there they they
were in such a panic they hadn't even
shut off the Machinery so this thing was
going and you're hearing this guy's head
not ding ding ding ding ding by then it
was like a wet noodle you know a giant
wetness it's just disgusting dude and
you told him you know why would you turn
this off and they they're you know they
it made sense no we didn't we didn't
want to see it uh we don't want to stop
we don't want to see it we don't know
what to do so when you turn that thing
off and you see that dude wrapped up in
there and the fact that dude you want to
talk about fake you know what I mean I
mean it looked totally fake it didn't
look like a human being at all and cops
have to respond to that oh yeah anything
that happens like that any industrial
cops are always the first on everything
because firemen are at this station
playing video games you know yeah utter
having hot dogs hell yeah dude I went I
used to date a fireman's daughter dude
they'd invite me anything they were
doing all they were doing hot dogs best
job ever every time dude they're like
you wanna we're doing this big event I
get to the event every time it was 11
dudes sitting down eating hot dogs
having a good time playing games
watching best job the the one thing cops
and firemen have in common is they all
wanted we all want to be firemen man
really oh hell yeah dude if I can go
back in time best job in the world yeah
I got nothing but admiration for him
dude and the world the world loves them
the world loves firemen dude you know
they ain't holding nobody accountable
and everything's a science tooth
environment they
oh God firemen are gonna hate me they do
see all the tragedy and death which is
brutal and I I feel for them in that but
the other side of it is is that
everybody loves them yeah because all
they're doing is saving and helping and
everything that they do essentially is
science you know I mean it's a fire if
it comes in contact with that we know
what's going to happen the wind's
blowing this way we know what's going to
happen it's all pretty predictable it's
not that thing it's there's aspects that
are dangerous but you know yeah you guys
it is a lot more uh
it's a lot more hypothesis like
hypothesizing in the moment going on
yes there's not like a lot of even house
fires if there's a house fires cops are
always the first ones on it dude I'd
shoot if I saw a cop a house for odd
damn shoot at it
that's who I'd be that way again man the
expectation is if you're a cop and you
get there and someone's screaming my
baby's inside my babies oh hell yeah go
to an award ceremony for the end of the
year at a police department there's
always at least one cop that went into a
burning building to to to to help
somebody wow because firemen takes a
while to get there yeah yeah well I'll
see yeah it's like it's so hard to get a
group of guys to do anything together
especially yeah and that truck is so
hard to get through it's like get them a
little
you know I guess we have to have water
in it huh well the water's already there
yeah yeah well yeah they're I think
they're already full I don't know man
our relationships with cops and firemen
is kind of crazy when I was on graveyard
just because I was so jealous of the
life they lived and things I would call
them out for anything three o'clock in
the morning dude you're not feeling good
man you need to be seen by paramedic all
right let me hook this up and I would we
need paramedics just and they knew it
because we eventually become friends
because they're in the same station yeah
totally they would see me and be upset
but you know I love stopping by fire
stations man fire fire dudes have always
been cool and it's nice to get it to go
in there you know uh great job yeah it's
cool man especially in New Orleans like
we always love them because they also
are part of the parades so that's a big
thing in Louisiana is firemen get this
whole second they have this whole second
like
appreciation because the fire trucks are
in the parades a lot oh yeah so you see
a lot of that huh I was cheering them
waving flags yeah what uh what do you
think's like one of the biggest
um problems that's facing police right
now I mean I know you said some of the
PTSD and
um and I say you said low Staffing too
or the fear that people don't like a bad
Public Image you know
um yeah I I've seen bad public images
not doing it justice the biggest
the biggest issues for police right now
first and foremost it always has been
but they're now just starting to
acknowledge it and talk about it and and
get real programs in place number one
killer of cops is suicide yeah that's a
weird statement to say but like like I I
got a guy I worked with who's in Texas
right now he's he's working in a program
a religious program that reaches out and
helps cops and firemen and First
Responders with mental wellness and
that's what they call Dina uh Charter
Oaks Charter Oaks Academy or no not
Charters Charter Oak something but he um
he just made me aware that this one
police department in the last couple
months six hot cops killed themselves
you know you just don't hear about that
because it's bad publicity cops don't
even want that out you know it's a scary
thing when someone says oh cops are all
killing themselves wow all the cops are
unstable there just is no good publicity
for cops you know so and what's happened
recently
what happened this last time
with the uh the riots and the the
political aspect that got involved and
allowed it to continue and the way it
was put on the media and portrayed
it's it's it set us back a lot it set
policing back a lot it's it's cops are
scared to do their job
you know they're just scared to do their
job they didn't I can imagine I can't
even imagine yeah the public doesn't
understand you know once when a guy
comes
it's it's difficult to describe but it's
life and death you know cops shouldn't
have to die just because
you know that the people want the fight
to be fair there is no fight here my job
is to get him in custody and take him
before magistrate that's it right and I
gotta do what I gotta do to give me
custody but if this guy's fighting me
the way he is he'll kill I have to I
have to think he'll kill me to get away
I have no choice yeah especially if a
guy that's already killed other people
or done thing you know like this is a
bad guy it's not a good guy yes who's
here on the ground it's like this ain't
a great guy yes you know this ain't a
guy who's been doing great stuff or
learning Spanish or something all day
this is somebody who has is been doing
crime
um how big is race becoming history I
was just gonna say that is that where it
gets to
um is that is that like be it become a
big problem I can only give you my
experience right so I'm only speaking
for me I I worked at two different
police departments in the two police
departments I worked in one of the
communities was predominantly black of
South Central the other was
predominantly Hispanic Hispanic white
you know a little bit of everything
um
systematic the statement that the police
are systematically racist I know for 100
it's not true because
I was part of the police I was part of
these two police departments and
if it was there I'd tell you did I see
it I absolutely I absolutely did I in my
entire career in the field I saw two
guys that I felt like that guy is
treating that person different based on
the color of his skin okay it's not too
bad over the whole course of it the
whole course one guy was blatant it was
blatant you know I mean and they
actually got rid of him relatively quick
um the other guy wasn't as Blaine but it
did appear that way what is the reality
of it is is that when you work in a
community usually that Community is it's
predominantly something oh yeah that's
predominantly something and it's not
that you because in my experience in my
police departments I worked with black
guys Hispanic guys Asian guys we were
everything everything was women you know
especially California yes everything was
represented and within those walls there
was it didn't matter you know what I
mean if it if it if it did exist it was
something that we did with amongst each
other ingest right like yeah the guy
that I worked with his black ripping on
me because some stereo stupid stereotype
about white people or whatever you know
is something we would do and joke about
but I never saw anyone treat anyone any
different because of the color skin
unfortunately what would happen is that
you'd be in these communities and you
would develop
I don't even like to use the word
prejudice but you would develop
um feelings about the way these
communities operate because you're
constantly coming in contact with the
worst of it right you know what I mean
constantly in any scenario
right if I'm working in an all-black
Community all or predominantly black
probably Latino community and I'm a
officer then I'm I'm coming in contact
with the bad guys from that Community
yes yes you're dealing with the bad guys
and you start to develop over years and
years and years of the same and and
there are there are unique aspects to
different types of communities you know
the crimes and the way the things that
people do in Hispanic Community are
different than the black community
different to the White Community
different in the Asian community so
there are things that go on that are
repetitive where you start getting
callous towards it so it wasn't a matter
of
people being racially prejudiced it was
a matter of being it's a terrible word
but prejudice against
specific aspects of a culture
you know specific aspects of a culture
like I can give you ones that are are
very controversial there's a lot of
the Hispanic community
is really divided up there's first
generation Hispanics there's 2nd j3 and
they're very different within themselves
like our first hat generation Hispanic
people to come here
hard-working kind loving family
just ever just good people right you
know I mean you'd go like hey man come
stay with me for a week and not even
think about it but they were super super
hard drinkers you know they would get
together for quinceanera and you'd get
calls at three o'clock in the morning
and they're all beating the [ __ ] out of
each other yeah because they're all so
drunk you know or at a two-year-old's
birthday party you get there and go like
it's a [ __ ] two-year-old's birthday
party why are you guys drunk and it's
three o'clock in the morning but it was
prevalent so you would get callous
towards that oh yeah yeah and it's fun
getting [ __ ] up around a kid sometimes
you know if you unless you're getting
real weird yeah yeah well there's a lot
of that too but in every community that
I dealt with
foreign you would have that and people
would start identifying stuff and things
would start
becoming you would develop calluses
towards it right but yeah you're like
systematic racism or some of this you
never thought you had you never said oh
man and when they say that it's so
frustrating because
I see some of them and I and the the
um the incident where the dude knelt on
his neck
totally wrong as a police officer you're
looking at that and going like okay
for him to get in that situation I can
with I'm not going to judge for him to
get a situation where these guys need
his neck I'm not gonna judge because
that can happen I've been in situations
where it happens right where you're
trying to get a guy in custody even
though he's handcuffed he is still doing
stuff that can cause harm to himself and
others right
there's no reason why that guy didn't
after 10 to 15 seconds stand up and put
try to put that guy back into the car
right so what he started doing and in
the world insinuated that guy's racist
well we don't know if that had anything
to do with the color of that guy's skin
all we do know is is that guy crossed
the line and should face consequences
because he started administering
punishment um
at this where he was at and that is not
his job his job is into custody and even
if in his thought process his intent was
not to administer punishment
he should know better than to
put be in that situation for any length
of time because it can cause harm that
guy was wrong right but to insinuate
that it was race based and if I'm I
didn't watch it but
I don't think anything ever even came
out where this there was ever anything
in this guy's background where there was
any instance of racism whatsoever yeah
yet if you go to ask anyone right now
they're going to say oh that was racist
cops are racist right we have no idea
that it could have been could have been
you know we'd have to be intimately
involved I imagine if there was any
proof of that they would have put it out
everywhere yeah if they had found
something it would have been everywhere
well it's interesting now too because
almost the race narrative is starting to
this it's starting to evaporate over
time because and I think in some
communities obviously in the South
there's a ton of that every you know
there's historical like biases and like
black people didn't have opportunities
or money they had to do what they could
to survive yes you know and then you
have cops who were predominantly white
probably and they they were policing
crimes and crime is a lot of times
things you have to use to survive you
know certainly like at times in the past
you know
um but it's interesting that uh
uh shoot were we talking about what did
you say racism yeah so it's interesting
that yeah because now it's like police
forces are getting pretty diverse super
diverse right and so I've almost
wondered would it be better to have a
policeman of that ethnicity show up
absolutely you know and they're all
starting to go towards that yeah they
are my Police Department is predom when
I started predominantly white when I
left it's getting predominantly Hispanic
and I think that's smart I think it's
it's actually smart does it make it a
little harder for the guy that's white
that wants to get it get a job you know
well he's just gonna have to find a
different Community I guess you know but
yeah it's it's it's definitely going
that direction and it's definitely it's
almost like they should have it it's
like okay we have you know uh two white
suspects and two black suspects let's
send a black police officer and a white
police officer you know if you
unfortunately in police work you don't
have that time to go I guess a
dispatcher could right they would know
based on what what they have out there
of who to send to what but again you're
policing specific areas it's it would be
harder than you think right and it's
crazy that we're having to even think
about that kind of stuff right but it's
like you get so many like civil lawsuits
and so many it's just like we've just
taxed ourselves at the [ __ ] guilt you
know it's like we've
I don't even think that would from my
experience that's not even a girl well
yeah we will and I think it's a good
move but it's not a cure-all because
I've seen I've been in at scenes where a
guy I was with was black officer and
I've seen people attack him just like
they were attacking me what I mean
because it wasn't really about they
hated that guy because of the uniform I
mean that guy that with my name tagged
me white he didn't know who I was he the
way he was attacking me and all that it
was my uniform and the fact on top of it
that I was white but I see them do the
same thing it's just they don't like the
police they just don't like the police
there's just certain people that don't
like the police yeah and I think it's
interesting too because it's like some
cultures like Black Culture never really
had a like America was always kind of a
kind of a white culture country probably
you know I mean it was there was
diversity for sure but I think like the
people that ran the country were
probably
predominantly white probably probably so
then I think a lot of society kind of
has a white ring to it so I think only
now are you seeing a lot more
um Society getting really pretty diverse
you know so I think you're starting to
see what these other cultures how what
they even like to have in society or
what they like their societies to be
like yes and so I think you're seeing
like a merging of that like some
societies they might not like to have
any rules or any policing there you know
some they think that they think that
right oh yeah they think that they think
that but they if you took the police out
of some certain communities communities
that have more problems if you
completely took the police out of it and
they knew the police they would implode
it would be there there would be no
Community wow it would be no Community
because criminals are going to be
criminals you know people are gonna
they're gonna feed on the week knowing
that there's nothing there to stop them
they're going to get theirs wow at any
extent the pulley the policing is
completely totally necessary how we how
we do it is just going to continue to
evolve yeah you know but it's right now
it's it's good there's a good basis in
place what's happening to them is
totally unfair
but we just got to get through this and
good will come of this amen it's
unfortunate you know but good will come
of this good came of Rodney King great
things came from the Rodney King
accident it really I saw it I lived it I
watched the change oh absolutely when I
first started there was a lot of stuff
that went on that slowly I watched it
get you know when you're when you're new
you just kind of stand back I watched it
slowly get eliminated slowly get better
things slowly improve on the way they
handle stuff you know yeah it's it's
it's definitely getting better and and
it's it's gonna get better but we have
you know I just I just hope they
continue to be fair because there's a
lot of good dudes that are just yeah I
think look I'm grateful for them man I'm
really grateful for him yeah they deal
with a lot of they deal with a lot of
stuff you know not yeah not everybody
gets gets to not everybody sees the
stuff you know nobody not everybody sees
someone blow their head off you know
what I mean try that once see how that
changes your life I can't even imagine
it really take one person and watch one
time watch someone in front of them blow
their head off and then and then see how
it changed do an experiment follow that
guy around see how that changes life now
take that guy that same guy and do it
for 20 years every single day
you know what do you expect you know
yeah I can't I lose it if somebody has
left like a big thing a piece of chunk
of hair like if they had a bunch of hair
in the drain
I would like yeah I couldn't even that
makes me nervous
and probably the thought about it going
back like give the example of that I
watched the guy put a double barrel
shotgun in his mouth was when his mom
was standing outside and blow his head
off yeah standing standing in the
doorway remember back in the day in the
older houses in Whittier they had those
screen doors you know the decorative
stuff on the front it was a screen door
the mom came running out screaming hey
my son my son he's suicidal and she kind
of got behind me by the car and I looked
over at the house and the door was open
the screen door was there and the guy
walked right up to the screen door he
had one of those old school double
barrel shotguns stuck it in his mouth
and pulled the trigger
his his head expanded like a cartoon the
gases expanded his head it was I can't I
can't do justice and trying to get you
to understand what it looked like
mom freaking out just the Dynamics of
that scenario right there then on top of
it I had to go inside the house and I'm
pushing the screen door to get this guy
because he he basically Las Vegas hotel
explosion falled right in front of the
door so I'm trying to push him out of
the way and it didn't even dawn on me as
I'm pushing in
his brain matter was on the seeing it
fell into the back of my shirt
yeah
which to this day I can feel it you know
what I mean now this is this is one
small scenario imagine that happening to
you one time
how that would change the course of your
life I know it sounds dramatic but don't
you think it would yeah don't you think
it would look a lot of stuff different
don't you think you would feel a lot
different so yeah I don't know if I
would keep being able to feel after a
certain point right yeah and then have
to keep it in that I had to keep that
thing I had to keep it in my shirt for
like four hours dude we tried to wash it
out and all that but it came down to
take it off my shirt and vest and
everything it was
but once sorry I was just gonna ask a
question
um you mentioned all these violent
situations but you're a homicide
detective was that fulfilling is it
fulfilling like helping my other person
no that was my least favorite that was
absolutely my least favorite assignment
it's the what was homicide detective
here yes yes uh it's the one I it's the
one I work towards my whole career
and then once I got into it
um it was just there was no real
satisfaction there was satisfaction in
catching the person that did it but it
was overshadowed by what the ACT
left everyone around it in you know
again I had domestic violence I had I
could I had a domestic violence
situation with that was I can say was
gratifying and catching who did it and
such but a lot of the gang ones it just
didn't matter it just didn't matter you
know you would catch the guy and he some
someone else would do it or he'd get out
and do it again and and there was so
much Sadness and Sorrow surrounding it
because the court cases were long and
drawn out
um you were sitting with the family for
for sometimes years getting through
these processes and you were the last
attachment that they had to these people
so they would become really attached to
you they would bring me Christmas
presents you know even after I the case
was done and I would I would politely
tell them I I can't accept this for a
lot of reasons but the primary one is is
I I can't have this relationship I can't
have this emotional tie to you because I
got a million more of these and if I
start doing that I'm done you know I
mean this has to be you have to be your
groceries that I bagged and you got to
take that bag of groceries and you got
to get out of here because I got to get
on to the next one and it's just it's
it's too much mentally to have an
emotional tie with you whatsoever so
homicide was a lot of that and it was
awesome it has to be heartbreaking
heartbreaking because it's heartbreaking
to them to it's like even when I was a
gang member even when it was a gang
member that was killed that was a brutal
murderer himself
he had a mom and I was always in contact
with that Mom you know what I mean and
it just it would just it was almost
impossible to deal with and I'm I'm a
little I admit it man going into it I'm
a little too sensitive to have probably
done this job but it was just draining
man there's no good scenario in homicide
and then if you don't catch the guys
that did it stays there it weighs on you
it weighs on you that you couldn't you
couldn't do it you know you couldn't
figure it out you failed this guy's
gonna do it again so there's almost a
level of
responsibility that is homicide was a
different Beast I
no bueno man no good you know there were
I got a lot of good things out of other
assignments do you think there's a lot
of serial killers out there still
serial killers depends on your
definition of a serial kill seems hard
to do now well if your definition is a
serial killer is someone that kills a
lot of people yeah yeah there is there's
gang members that there's gang members
out there that have killed five six
seven people and they're going to kill
more people but the world doesn't look
at that guy as a serial killer it
doesn't fit the definition or if you go
to a training class they're not teaching
you that this guy is a serial killer you
know what I mean yeah the quintessential
serial killer is so uncommon yeah so so
so uncommon it just nobody's
breaking into home strangers homes and
you know doing the um Night Stalker [ __ ]
is there a hypothesis that when you get
into that job that that'll be what it's
like and stuff is there that kind of
like kind of kind of you know and it's
like anything when you look I mean I
in an industry like this I imagine you
look at someone that's doing something
else and going like oh that's right oh
yeah you think that's where I want to be
that's where I want to be because that's
where it's happening and then you get
there and you go [ __ ] this ain't that
great you know I want to so I want to be
there I want to be there no matter what
you get there and you go like
at least my experience is it's not what
I thought it was it was actually better
back there I want to go back there
because that was a lot better this this
but homicide I mean look at the
infatuation with cops look at my TV
shows and movies he's saying everything
everything killing it's like yeah I
think I've seen every episode of True
Crime
the world's infatuated with it and what
you're seeing is that you're seeing that
fake not fake you're seeing that
surface
aspect of it you're not seeing the stuff
that we've been talking about you know
what's behind all that but you're seeing
that so even going into it you go like
oh look at that dude that dude's been
around he
the reality of it is he's so [ __ ] up
and callous that he's totally quiet and
cool you know I want to be that guy man
I want to do that [ __ ] got a suit on
looking good
workout people always go hey you work
homicide you ever work homicide you
could be a homicide detective and it's
just again it goes back to that thing as
you just don't get it you know what I
mean homicide is where you want to get
but when you get there just my
experience was I just wanted to get the
[ __ ] out I just
um so you graduated finally you're out
I'm out I'm retired they got to pay me
for the rest of my life Amen brother you
deserve it I I hope so I think so you
know it's it's I can't even I'm it's
it's not a tremendous amount of money
but it's a it's a good chunk that most
people don't have and and what else do
you want to do after do you start to
develop different thoughts or things
that you I'm working I work for a
company a big company that owns lots of
businesses and I do asset protection for
them you know just real
surface
investigations of money crimes and you
know basic simple
almost stupid but no pressure it's dumb
what I do I admit it but they pay me
well and sometimes I get a little antsy
and go God my life look at my life now
my life is so boring and this sucks and
I gotta do something else but
I got a wife I love I got a kid I adore
and you know I got fam I just this this
is good I'll ride this out you know does
your child want to be an officer [ __ ] no
all right we made that clear day one and
my kid was little we made that very
clear with one sentence you will [ __ ]
never be a cop all day so don't even
think about it don't dream about it
don't anything it will never [ __ ]
happen what about a fireman ah [ __ ] yeah
hell yeah I'll do anything to get him as
a fireman yeah dude let's give him some
Franks right with the understanding that
there's going to be trauma but police
work man
there's just if I could go back in time
as much as my experience
there's there was joy that I hold on to
and go God that was that was awesome I'm
so glad I did that was exciting my life
is this and
people want to hear it's crazy to think
people want to hear about it you got me
sitting here talking about what I did
and it is a crazy thought they go people
actually are interested because they
don't understand
and when they hear it they go whoa
that's kind of that's [ __ ] really
crazy that's crazy to me because that's
just what I did you know what I mean so
there's aspects I would say oh it would
be sad if I never did that but if I go
back in time I would
totally totally totally do something
different wow but I got here by luck I
never planned on being a cop like I said
my my growing up was either a criminal
you're not a criminal no but I was I was
doing that but I was a deviant I was I
was insecure and doing bad things man
you know what I mean yeah you know but
my how I became a cop this is back in
the day is I had nothing going I had no
plans man you know I was
doing nothing I
there was just no future so I started
coaching my little brother's pop warner
team with my dad and the guy that was
coaching with me was a instructor in the
police academy and literally one day
during the game he's going what are you
doing now man I don't know I got nothing
going on he goes I'll get you the
[ __ ] police academy a couple weeks if
you want and I went
all right that sounds cool man let's do
it and that's that's how it happened wow
it's [ __ ] how it happened I woke up
the next day and I was pulling out on
the street with a gun and a police car
going like these guys got no [ __ ]
idea you know what I mean they got no
idea but it it served me well it served
my background served me well I was able
to do that job I think better than most
strictly based on experience and
compassion you know of understanding the
dynamic of taking away someone's
freedoms a big [ __ ] deal and we need
to avoid that at all costs we need to
avoid that at all costs then getting
them in the system and getting this
record and all the things that come with
it I knew the magnitude of it I I didn't
take it lightly ever even you know I
used to get
17 18 year old girls for DUIs and it was
gut wrenching to me you know it was
gut-wrench me boys anybody was just gut
wrenching of taking them and putting
them in a jail cell and realizing this
is going to change the course of your
life forever you know hopefully it'll be
positive but this is they would be
crying and it was just traumatic it was
just traumatic most cops
you know let's go get the [ __ ] in the
cell and let's get past this and you
were drunk and I saved lives and I got
to get out there and I got to find some
real crime you know what I mean I can
remember sitting and thinking like
talking to them in this cell and just
going like it's gonna be okay right it's
gonna be okay I know you hate me right
now but it's it's gonna be okay and and
you one thing I do know I hope is you're
never going to be here again right and
you didn't kill nobody you know what I
mean so those kind of aspects for me
I've really looked back and go like
I I was meant to be there as as much as
I didn't deserve maybe to be there and
the way it just happened to me to be
there wouldn't be able to share this
story today too with us too you know
because yeah like I feel too much I've
always been too much of a feeler you
know and so I think you need people that
have a little extra feeling sometimes to
get out of instances sometimes and share
you know share some of the feeling side
of it and I'll be especially your job
I'll be judged I'll be judged based on
this from people of the industry people
in the industry will absolutely Judge Me
based on this is literally believe it or
not this is the absolute first [ __ ]
time I have ever publicly said anything
about my childhood and being arrested
and being in custody I worked with guys
who are my friends who I care deeply
about and I'd never made mention of it
and so much time went on I just thought
it's irrelevant and there's no reason to
bring it up and I just never did I just
buried it this is the absolute first
[ __ ] time I've ever admitted that and
it'll be interesting I don't know who's
gonna see it or what it'll be
interesting to see what I'm an old guy
now you know know it's interesting to
see if people actually come back at me
and go you [ __ ] or whatever it
is the reaction I get [ __ ] criminal
but I do hope that people do listen to
it and go like hey
what's there's some to it it's
fascinating man and it's fascinating you
know we had a border patrol security guy
on one time and
um which is just a public service job I
get you know in a way or some something
in the same world a little bit yes but
it was interesting to hear about the
border and the things that go on there
and the people that are getting run back
and forth across there and how cartels
own different pieces of land there so if
you even want to transport someone
across a piece of land you have to pay
that cartel even to like coyote somebody
across the land and how a lot of the
people coming in some of them aren't
even Mexican yeah and a lot of them are
[ __ ] you know uh Middle Eastern and
they're [ __ ] a lot of pedophile a lot
of Crete just [ __ ] was like Jesus Christ
there's a lot of aspects to that that
you don't even think of that we dealt
with on a daily basis a lot of people
that come in are obviously coming here
because they want a better life totally
down for that you know there's just a
process we just need the process just do
it the legal process come everybody come
but let's just go through this process
because we need that process because you
wouldn't believe how many people come
here and they don't have the means or
they just like they don't have car
insurance right they don't they're all
these different things that they're just
bypassing where it's causing such
turmoil in our world and our system you
know I mean that was those are the
problems well all of that it's all like
how long are we going to strain this the
walls of our systems you know I mean we
already don't even you know and then I
still expect people
to put a president on television and be
like America you know it's like don't
sell me this [ __ ] thing if you're not
uh
uh if it's not a real product right yeah
and that's what's really kind of
happened I think it's that's a lot of
kind of what's you know it's one of the
issues they back it up into one thing
you know if you're against it they say
well you're racist yeah I'm not a racist
at all I couldn't give a [ __ ] the only
reason I even think about is because you
keep talking about it but I just want
them to come here I want them here let's
make sure they have a path to get here
oh yeah but let's just follow the rules
to get here that's it we have to have
roll call you have to have like if you
don't know inventory any business that
doesn't have good inventory will go out
of business if you don't have no what's
on the shelves or know what's here or
what's there it's going to go out of
business man and that's what [ __ ]
starts to get scary because you have
other people that are like well I was
born here I'm just trying to play by
whatever rules I was born into maybe
they were more fortunate than some other
places I don't know in some ways they
probably were in some ways they probably
weren't but
um but I'm just trying to play by the
[ __ ] rules and everybody's got to
play by the rules and when our
government is even playing by the rules
anymore then it's like well then it
makes it tough to think that someone
just an everyday man is gonna be like
okay I'm Gonna Keep playing by him and I
think that makes you guys's job even
tougher because it's like now you're
having to almost do a government's job
well we are police departments are the
government
right but they're just that Wing that
it's got to take care of all that that
stuff right and you shouldn't be like
the you're the most accessible part of
the government too for people and that's
[ __ ] kind of scary because you have
people if they don't like the government
or they think this or they think that
then you're the person that they can
really reach to take it out on you know
I don't know I'm just kind of rambling
not me not not anymore you're free baby
free man what were so many news topics
we wanted to hit before we get this man
out of here
um not specifically news but I did want
to hear about when you were on the show
Cops oh yeah good call oh yeah okay so
so cops super interesting um they used
to watch that as a family God yeah I
used to watch it too crazy
um I met Roseanne Barr last night how
was that
the awesomest time oh really dude I was
how did that get why'd you bring out
frozen bar right now I just I don't know
I thought about it and I was so excited
and I meant to tell you a little while
ago did you ever see her show Growing Up
oh absolutely oh
did I'm on stage at the comedy store
right and I hear this laugh in the back
and only one other time it happened to
me was Damon Wayans I heard his life and
I grew up watching his laugh and I heard
her laugh and I and it [ __ ] just
flipped him I didn't know that she was
back there
and I was like oh my God that Roseanne
Bar is just in the room tonight in the
crowd you know there's probably 200
people in there or something sold out
and she was nice she was howling
laughing so then I'm like I got I want
to do the best I can like for all the
years that she made me laugh or made me
feel or made me feel like I you know
mattered in the [ __ ] Universe with
that poor family that they that they
worked on
um I wanted to just do have that one
moment to like give as much back of that
as I could yeah and I crossed right on
and then I got to meet her after and
anyway I was just so freaking excited
um and some girl came up and was like I
don't want you to tell and I even said
to that girl you are a menace right now
okay I've worked too hard to get some
meat roses right and you are [ __ ]
ruining it
that's funny
is you just kept telling Roseanne
finally was like you are ruining it
oh it was so good that's funny that
Roseanne Barr did that for you anyway I
mean look there was definitely some
other women did it too but she yeah yeah
she that had an impact and I just love
her comedy and they tried to cancel her
and it just [ __ ] and was like [ __ ]
them would they try to cancel her for
they canceled her for some uh she had a
tweet that the Twitter said was racist
and she referenced like uh I don't
remember what it was but it wasn't
racist it was just like the general term
and they you know you know how Twitter
was hopefully it'll get better but
anyway let's get the cops let's hear so
cops the way cops operates is is that
there's there's there's a few film Crews
there's a sound guy and there's a camera
guy
and I think I I don't remember how many
minutes about it was very few like four
or five of these teams and these guys
were so interesting um they essentially
go out and by the time they came to our
Police Department it had really changed
uh because of civil law where you
weren't able just to film [ __ ] and throw
it on TV you had to get waivers from
everyone that was involved and that
involved criminals signing off saying
yeah you can use that [ __ ] which is
[ __ ] so stupid if you signed off on
that [ __ ] you're the dumbest guy on the
face of the Earth because it's all now
evidence it could be used against you in
court so it was really tough to get
those guys to sign off but believe it or
not you know unfortunately when it comes
to Crime you're not dealing with a lot
of Scholars so you would get a lot of
signatures but by then it was a little
tougher so what they would do is is they
would ride with you they would pick an
officer and they they I I was fortunate
enough to be picked and they would ride
with you for two months every single
shift
yeah and that time I was working three
twelves which is three shifts twelve
three twelve hour shifts Friday Saturday
Sunday which was the busiest that's why
at graveyard so that's why they wanted
to ride with me so you would go out with
these guys and it and the man it was
like it was like it was like performance
anxiety you know what I mean it's like
oh yeah I felt this 20s yeah right Jesus
I just felt this need to perform man you
know and and it's harrowing police work
is some days there's just nothing going
on you know you gotta you gotta
self-generate whether it be tickets and
hope you can come up with stuff so I
always felt this pressure to go out but
speaking with these guys and their
experiences like the the sound guy had
been shot yeah in the leg
um uh the other guy something that
happened their stories were awesome
because they had been all over they were
telling me stories dude I'm just going
like [ __ ] that is so awesome dude I
can't even believe you experienced all
this [ __ ] that you've experienced I mean
these guys probably walked away from
that show and have mental problems
themselves yeah because they they've
essentially were cops all the time on
patrol well imagine you're a sound guy
and you're like oh it sounds like
somebody got shot and then it's [ __ ]
you
whatever you know I mean they had all
kinds these guys had great stories so
essentially they would ride with you the
whole time and the issue became is you
felt so much pressure to get material oh
yeah
um that when they rode with me they rode
with two different officers me and
another guy and I literally didn't make
the show
I literally didn't make the show I
didn't why and the one time I did the
guy wouldn't sign off and they couldn't
make the cuts to make it relevant so I
they I literally didn't make but I
actually became really good friends with
these guys because we'd spent so much
time and talking that I I was talking to
him I don't now but I was talking to him
for quite a bit calling where you at and
what's going on and wow
but the way that they do cops is when
when you watch it it looks like it's
it's it's Progressive it looks like this
is happening you know what I mean and it
never registers with you and like they
go they're in the car and they get the
radio call and it's like ah you know
372 respond to non-breather yeah
whatever it is and you see the cop okay
and then all of a sudden he's driving
and then it cuts away and you see the
car making a right hand turned onto a
street and never really registers you
would go well how the [ __ ] did they know
he was going there to be on that thing
you know what I mean I'm a guy that has
no idea of the industry and editing all
that so it wasn't until they rode with
me and I watched the cops and I went
well how the [ __ ]
are they gaining all these angles and
[ __ ] so what ends up happening is find
out is they would we would have the
situation they would get out and they
would they would be in it I mean you
would have to literally tell these guys
look at dude you need to step the [ __ ]
back you know you need to get behind
that car right now I get it but I I need
you to do that so they were always up on
you and they'd be filming and getting
everything they can and then they would
go back and go hey look I think this is
something we can use so this is what I
need you to do I need you to drop my
camera guy off on that corner and I want
you to go back to this
Street and then I want you to fake like
you're responding to the radio I'm going
to be in it filming you you know with
the other camera
so there's acting involved you know what
I mean and I was a young kid and I just
couldn't do it dude I'm just not an
actor you know what I mean so they would
like be filming so all those guys you
see doing it that's all acting up until
the actual scenario wow but you never
really never really crossed my mind no
yeah in my mind I'm just saying oh that
makes sense they have footage everywhere
and they're just getting all the you
know that's like they're just dialed in
and getting everything that's
okay now I want you to come and open
that door you know what I mean and then
you go back and watch an episode and go
okay now this [ __ ] makes sense why
didn't that ever register with me this
is all [ __ ] you know I mean except
for the actual scenarios themselves yeah
you know they would just film it raw and
they would do their editing magic and
and make an episode but it takes it
takes two months every single night with
two different teams for a half hour
episode
and they said they struggle sometimes to
get that damn yeah
I've struggled to get it brother right
yeah
um
it's weird that we're watching cry is it
weird that we watch crime that we devour
it like that what does it do to our
psyche when we just see crime when we
see
murder disappearing you know
what does it do to us over time I I've
that's I couldn't even answer that
question I always think how I always
think wow I wonder how did I think about
this kind of [ __ ] before I was exposed
to all this [ __ ] because I don't think
the same way you do
you know I mean you don't think the same
way I do
because I have a different perspective
of it'd be like me having an opinion and
the way I think about what I just
explained movies videos editing you know
I don't I don't understand how it works
I don't know what's going on I don't
know what it all pertains
same deal with police work I don't
remember how I thought before which is
how you would think about it in its
entirety you know cops what they do
what's going on all that kind of [ __ ]
because I did it for 20 years so I watch
people when they watch these shows and
most of the shows I go [ __ ] this is so
stupid I can't even watch this dude
because the world thinks this is what it
is and this is so far from what it is
this is just entertainment but I I I I
don't know what the fascination with it
because I see it and I just go
I'll watch it and in my mind
there'll be a scene where I've seen cop
movies where like these guys with AK-47s
in the streets and shoot which is
totally unrealistic but anything like a
shooting or anything and for me it just
makes me feel bad
you know I mean for me it's just nine
times out of ten it'll make me think of
something that's inside my brain that I
don't even remember and know that it's
there anymore that all of a sudden like
the example we said earlier I'll see a
kid in a red jacket and also I'll
I'll literally watch that kid and it
just did it again that ran into traffic
yeah I watched that kid die again I
always go like what the [ __ ] you know
why the [ __ ] am I thinking about that
and when is that finally going to be
gone and that's so crazy and that's all
[ __ ] I'm doing to myself in my mind I'm
not talking about it I'll talk to my
wife about it but that's my experience
that happens to me a lot you know I mean
it happens to me a lot little triggers
what they call them you know
and I think so and I won't it's never a
good time to go you know what I just
thought of honey
I just thought of the first time I
watched this [ __ ] guy that because I
saw a kid you just kind of keep it to
yourself because it's just the way that
it is
so when the rest of the world watches
that [ __ ]
I don't know dude I don't know what the
fascination is
the same idea I guess is why did you
want me to come in here and talk today
because I guess you people want to know
they want to know they want to know they
want to see they want to understand the
problem with TV is
that's that's a that's a leak that's a
very watered down version of reality
right and it's also a version that they
have mastered the like how to have the
algorithm of and make it entertainment
cheap to shoot as efficient as possible
blah blah blah blah and a lot of the
people the worst part is I think a lot
of cop maybe you know 50 years ago cop
shows or detective shows how much
somebody who involved in production may
have had a family member that was an
officer now it's like I feel like some
of these people making stuff are so far
removed from any of the reality of it
that uh they don't even have a human
sense of it and so you know absolutely
and if you watch as a cop if you watch a
show and you'll see it and you go do
someone in law enforcement had something
to do with this you can tell you can
tell you can tell someone someone that
knows a cop or is a cop or has been a
pastor they got a consultant or someone
someone told them that because no one
else would know that what about this man
and say it's a quiet night out there you
ever because there's a way to bust off
and get you a 20 minute nap in somewhere
oh hell yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah hell yeah
they had spots man especially on
graveyards three twelves after four
o'clock [ __ ] silent radio silent we
would yeah that's it man we would get
together because you want to be safe and
sleep in a group you know and like
wolves or something pretty much and one
guy was Lions you know lions sleep in a
group yeah everybody had there's always
one guy that had to stay up oh you know
I mean then that guy nine times out of
10 would [ __ ] fall asleep anyways you
know what I mean so I love that guy yeah
but that happened that happens every
night in in cities you know I mean just
you just have to you know you just gotta
do it in a responsible way and we would
have a couple times we would go behind
this church and it was a parking lot
that was really secluded with the walls
perfect you know we'd have like six cars
back there everybody's sleeping some of
the guys would even take off their belts
you know they get more comfortable yeah
laying sprawled across bring blankets to
lay over the middle and but we actually
would get woken up once while by the
priest he would come in the morning and
see us all there and knock on our window
and it became a thing you know we're all
thank you so much and he was cool about
he never told on us and you know it just
became our state it was really safe
because we had a priest yeah dude
yeah he's watching over us God literally
watching every that's pretty cool yeah
um did uh oh did they have you know a
lot of people sending people sending
videos a lot of like drug-induced
homosexuality like men that will do
drugs and then start making out you guys
see a lot of that out there uh in
Whittier we had a pretty prominent gay
community
um and but anybody being gay is just
kind of like that's normal that's like a
regular some people are gay some people
are straight some people are in the
middle
I'm talking about man that get geeked up
on pills or powder or uppers poppers and
all that kind of stuff yeah
methamphetamine is really big in the gay
community so will meth lead people to
being gay you think uh no you could give
me about a pound of math and I don't
think I'd ever be gay I don't think it
ever leads up to being gay but it
definitely it definitely uh I think it
enhanced the situations you know we had
a part yeah right it made it that's all
it takes there was a little enhancement
get that video Zach do we have it I'm
look I'm looking forward okay cool
thanks yeah we had a park where they
would where the gay community would get
together and kind of meet each other and
and and it was in the bathroom there was
this whole process that they they would
they would participate in to meet one
another and it was you'd stand at the
urinal in the public bathroom and if you
were standing there long enough and did
the right looks that the other guys
would know and it was hey how are you
and sometimes a little further so we
would have guys work um at that time
just because the people didn't like it
in the park and it became real prevalent
in one part right I mean and and
sometimes the sexual activity was a
little rampant paper much being
performed in a public park so they
wanted to go away so we'd had guys
undercover that would go in and stand
there and think we actually had an
officer that was standing there and he
made himself known as a police officer
because it became a parent and the guy
grabs his his junk and got a death grip
on it because he was scared you know and
and yeah the situation was hilarious
because he wouldn't let go and we all
had to come in and we're screaming at
this guy let him go let him go and the
guy's just holding on his weiner cops
yeah this guy's standing there with a
death grip on his thing and he doesn't
want to get in a fight or nothing
because there ain't a lot of holding
that on you know so right yeah all it
takes is one real meth head to rip hard
I imagine yeah something I don't want to
discover did um but do um
did uh did you some guys have to get
stationed in the bathroom sometimes
that's what we would do we would go in
the bathroom and put ourselves in the
situation too because it was a whole
process drugs were very prevalent yeah
hey can I give you some of this and that
because let's see what this is what's
happening we're seeing people sending in
this type of stuff here and these two
gentlemen you can
foreign
buddies you know but I think of the drug
that a certain point gets you pretty
close there you know like hey are we
yeah
it's like oh that's almost like a good
buy it doesn't really see that to me it
doesn't seem like really like homoerotic
behavior that just seemed like Two
Fellas like I'm [ __ ] up are you oh I
think it's you it looks like the one
guys maybe not totally into it and maybe
he's just trying to get a free slurpee
or something in it for him
but this is a lot of what's been going
on these days and people have been
sitting in a lot of videos like this
yeah we actually
um I when I was in homicide I actually
went to a training course where they
taught about
um in the community in the gay community
apparently based on the training I
received
there's something called it was called
they called it homosexual Overkill and
when there's murders involved in the gay
community it's usually really really
brutal really passionate really over the
top you know like chopping each other
chopping up and and I think the training
was just to make you aware when you came
to a murder if you saw something that
was completely over the top as far as
the way it went down that it was there
could be that vot it could be an Avenue
to start looking at you know maybe this
is a maybe a gay community thing where
we can get some information from like
Jeffrey Dahmer really essentially yeah I
mean I remember going to the training
and it was it was very graphic wow
whether that's true in its entirety or
not I don't know well gay guys I think
do everything to extreme kind of so I
don't think I'd be shocked if they're
like you know Julian a guy up or
something if he's being you know a bad
guy yeah
um I think we covered a lot of stuff
what do you think there Zach yeah we
pretty much covered everything in the
show a lot of stories Brad we look man I
think we'd love to even have you back
sometime we'll have you back when
there's a crime or something or if
there's something neat that we can talk
about I've just I've really enjoyed
learning about what uh some of your
experience has been like you know and
getting a little bit more of an
emotional aspect of of what an officer
goes through and could potentially go
through every day that's crazy when I
think about a 21 year old guy that's
rolling out of a parking lot yeah in a
in a vehicle and like in a different
time I mean a good time when cops were
looked at a little different I used to
post up at three o'clock in the morning
at the nightclubs getting out you know
because there was actually an appeal to
being a police officer so you know I
started in a good time and I ended in a
bad time for being a cop you know it's
it's but do you think we can get to a
better time again or do you think we
you're curious to see how we're going to
get there yeah I don't know we got to we
have to it's got to get better can't it
can't get any worse or we're going to be
in real trouble but I really appreciate
you have me in here and having the venue
to you know say some tell you some stuff
about what it really is like and I hope
it's been beneficial and it's been
awesome man it's been fascinating Brad
white uh thank you so much for your time
man absolutely thank you you bet happy
holidays
[Music]
I must be
Cornerstone
I'll share this piece of my life
[Music]
gonna take